Unkosten von Hackern auf dem regulären BTX-Konto ihrer Sparkasse verursacht, hätten Sie so etwas für möglich gehalten?
Frau Wirt, ganz ehrlich, sowas hätten wir nicht für möglich gehalten, denn wir hatten die Garantie der Post, dass unsere Zugriffsmittel zum Bildschirmtext geheim sind, geheim gehalten werden und von niemandem in Erfahrung gebracht werden können.
Werden Sie daraus jetzt Konsequenzen ziehen, als Anbieter und Nutzer von BTX?
Die erste Konsequenz haben wir bereits gezogen. Wir haben unser persönliches Kennenwort sofort geändert, sodass Herr Holland nicht ein weiteres Mal mit diesen Mitteln uns benachteiligen kann.
Und Ihre Einstellung zu hackern nach dieser etwas überraschenden Erfahrung?
Ich muss sagen, alle Hochachtung vor der Tüchtigkeit dieser Leute man muss sagen, es ist bedauerlich, dass erst durch den Beweis, den diese Leute erbracht haben, die Post davon überzeugt werden konnte, dass ihre Software, und darum handelt es sich, dass ihre BTX Software noch nicht allen Anforderungen gerecht wird.
Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 161. Mein Name ist Tim Pritlove und heute gibt es eine Ausgabe dieser Sendung, die mal wieder live stattfindet. Allerdings wird sie nicht live ausgestrahlt, also zumindest nicht auf dem Internet, sondern sie heilt hier nur durch die Fabrikhallen einer Tabakfabrik. Genaugenommen befinde ich mich gerade in Lins auf der Ars Electronica und das Ganze ist deshalb in einer Tabakfabrik, weil es solche eigentlich gar nicht mehr gibt, sondern diese Räume eben für diese Veranstaltung als Austragungsort verwendet werden. Eine Veranstaltung, die bisher immer ganz gut zersplittert war, quer über die ganze Stadt verteilt war und jetzt sich hier ganz gut zusammengespielt hat. Das hat den lustigen Nebeneffekt, dass hier verschiedenste Spaces sich haben herausbilden können, die es meines Wissens so bisher noch nicht gab auf der Ars Electronica. Und der konkrete Ort, an dem wir uns befinden, hört auf den lustigen Namen Teleinternet und versammelt so ein bisschen die Gemeinde um die Digital Communities, wie das hier genannt wird. Digital Communities, das umfasst halt alles Mögliche, Hacker-Spaces und eben all das, was jetzt hier im Programm auch schon häufig zur Sprache kam. Und auch der ein oder andere CRE-Gast ist hier schon gesichtet worden. Ja, und ich bin wiederum hier, weil ich die Gelegenheit hatte, hier einen Preis entgegenzunehmen. Allerdings nicht für mich oder für CRE, sondern ganz allgemein für den Chaos Computer Club. Der hat nämlich hier gewonnen. Und zwar so eine Gold-Else, das nennt man hier Golden Nica. Das ist einer der Hauptpreise. Es gibt deren fünf Kategorien und genau in dieser Kategorie Digital Communities hat der CCC dieses Jahr gewonnen, was wir natürlich alles ganz toll finden. Und da gab es dann hier irgendwie auch Gala und Tralala. Und jetzt wird das Ganze hier eher etwas informell abgefeiert. Ja, und deswegen sitze ich jetzt hier. Aber ich sitze jetzt hier nicht alleine und bringe wieder einen meiner bekannten Monologe, sondern ich habe, wie immer, Gäste und zwar alte Bekannte, nämlich Vic. Hallo, Vic. Melde dich. Und Andreas, Andreas Lehner, hallo. Ja, ihr wart beide schon mal zu Gast. Andreas, nur erst vor kurzem. Nachrichtendienste 159 hatten wir. Vic, und bei uns ist es schon ein bisschen her, ne? Ich habe jetzt gar nichts geguckt.
Ja, wir haben, glaube ich, damals in Gremlin gemeinsam über Datenrettung und Datenspeicherung und sowas gemacht.
So ist es. Ein paar Jährchen, ne? Insofern wurde es auch mal Zeit, dass du mal hier wieder auftauchst. Insofern alles super. Ja, warum sitzen wir jetzt hier? Also ich dachte mir halt, man könnte ja mal ausnahmsweise in diesem Programm auch mal über den Chaos Computer Club reden, weil das machen wir ja eigentlich relativ selten. Stattdessen wird immer über diverse andere Themen gesprochen. Und eigentlich haben wir so über den Club immer nur so nebenbei mal was fallen gelassen. Ich will jetzt auch nicht so den Topf aufmachen mit die Geschichte des Chaos Computer Clubs, weil wir haben hier nur bis 14 Uhr Zeit und jetzt ist 12 und das wird natürlich irgendwie nicht reichen. Außerdem kann man das eh immer nur so in Ansätzen alles machen. Aber was ich mal besprechen wollte, und da seid ihr eigentlich wirklich auch so die richtigen Gäste dafür, das ist mal ein bisschen darüber zu reden, wie denn das eigentlich so ist mit dem, was den Club so treibt und was vielleicht auch so dazu geführt hat, dass wir uns jetzt hier befinden. Vic, du bist ja nun schon ganz schön lange dabei, ne? Du zählst ja eigentlich offiziell, was man so als Urgestein bezeichnet.
Ja, naja gut, ich bin eben praktisch fast so lange dabei, wie es den Club gibt. Also das dürften jetzt, das sind noch nicht ganz 30 Jahre, denke ich.
Aber nächstes Jahr.
Und also, ja.
Wie war's? Wie war das so?
Naja, der Anfang, also der Anfang, es waren halt eine handvoll extreme Persönlichkeiten, die irgendwie auf ihre Art alle sehr kreativ gewesen sind und sich auf die Art, also der VAU hat halt einfach eines Tages den Begriff Chaos Computer Club in die Runde geschmissen. Und da fühlten sich auf einmal ein paar Leute angesprochen. Und ich gehörte auch dazu. Ich fühlte mich da auch sehr angesprochen. Also ich war nicht bei dieser Kommune-eins-Gründungsgeschichte dabei. Aber dann habe ich, ich habe in einem lokalen Hamburger Magazin irgendwann mal ein Interview von VAU gelesen und habe gedacht, das ist es, das ist es genau. Und dann habe ich mich sofort auf mein Moped geschmissen und bin hingefahren. Und VAU saß da und ja.
War das 81?
Ich, du frag mich bitte nicht nach Jahreszahlen. Bitte, das ist fast 30 Jahre her.
Aber 80er Jahre war es schon.
Das war ja, naja, das war vielleicht 81, vielleicht 82, irgendwas in der Preislage. Naja, und das, also wie soll ich sagen, ich hatte im Grunde genommen, ich hatte immer in meinem eigenen Kämmerchen mich beschäftigt mit, was weiß ich, eben mit Elektronik und Programmierung und bis hin zu Schaltungsdesign und all so ein Kram. Und damals gab es da kein Internet und ich meine, das können sich die Zuhörer heute nicht vorstellen. Es gab kein Netz. Ich meine gar keins. Ich meine, wenn man einen Akustikkoppler, wenn man den Hörer seines Bakelite-Telefons in einen Akustikkoppler gestopft hatte, dann gab es da vielleicht mal eine Handvoll Gegenstellen für auf dem Planeten. Und außerdem kam gleich die Deutsche Bundespost angeritten mit der Polizei und hat alles beschlagnahmt, weil das illegal war. Nee, also selbst den Hörer in den Akustikkoppler stecken, das war illegal. Das konnte zu einer Hausdurchsuchung führen. Das heißt, wenn du also einen Akustikkoppler hattest, der nicht von der Post gemietet war, und hast den Hörer da reingesteckt, dann war das strafbar. Ach echt?
Ich hatte das immer so in Erinnerung. Das ist nur das physikalische...
Und das sind schon einfach mal andere Zustände. Das, was früher echt unter Strafe stand, ist heute der erste Bürgerpflicht. Und ich bin auch der Meinung, dass wir damit so locker umgegangen sind, hat auch zur Beschleunigung des Wandels beigetragen. Denn irgendwann war es einfach nicht mehr haltbar, weil es irgendwann einfach zu viele... Man hätte ja nicht einfach alle Kids wegsperren können. Erst waren wir nur ein paar wenige, aber das hat sich ja relativ schnell eigentlich auch ausgebreitet. Und dann kamen ja eben diese Akustikkoppler und Mailbox Zeit und dann fingen an, die Mailboxen sich zu vernetzen. Die haben das dann praktisch zeitversetzt, die Nachrichten weiter transportiert. Und da fing eigentlich überhaupt erst das Netz an und das wurde auch relativ schnell global. Das war noch lange, lange vor Internet.
Also wobei das Internet gab es ja zu dem Zeitpunkt eigentlich schon. Nur halt nicht in Europa, gespeichert in Deutschland. Also es gab etwas, was...
Also den Begriff, ich wollte gerade sagen, es gab ja Apernet und so und da haben wir natürlich auch rumgehackt, wie blöd. Da waren aber eigentlich nur Forschungseinrichtungen zusammengesteckt. Da haben wir halt unsere Wechselfahrschule damals gemacht.
Hast du denn diesen BTX-Hack dann auch schon live mitverfolgt?
Selbstverständlich. Ich habe genau dieses Gerät mit dem Relais, damit bin ich jahrelang rumgelaufen. Das war so ein kleiner Olivetti M10 und der hatte halt so ein kleines Relais, um einen Kassettenrekorder an- und auszuschalten, um dort Software aufzuzeichnen oder Daten.
Dann holen wir jetzt noch mal richtig auf. Wir wissen ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt, wovon wir reden. Was ist passiert, also Bildschirmtext, dieser ZEPT-Standard, europäischer Standard, der, glaube ich, so wirklich nur in Deutschland und in Frankreich wirklich zu einer großen Verbreitung geführt hat.
In Frankreich war es ja dieses Minitale-System.
Genau, aber es war technisch weitgehend dasselbe. Es war im Wesentlichen dasselbe Konzept. Ich fand Bildschirmtext eigentlich immer sehr wegweisend, weil eigentlich ist es schon so ein bisschen World Wide Web gewesen.
Naja, es war insofern ein kaputtes Konzept, als wir uns eben gewünscht hätten, dass die Datenleitungen in Sende- und Empfangsrichtung gleich dick gewesen wären. Und Bildschirmtext führte eben als erstes die asymmetrische Geschwindigkeit ein, dass du eben mit 1200 BIT in der Sekunde empfangen hast und mit 75 nur gesendet. Das heißt, es war ganz eindeutig, wie soll ich sagen, es war mehr so eine Art Installation wie Fernsehen mit Rückkanal. Du darfst dann mal eine Votetaste drücken, aber es war nicht dazu gedacht, dass du selber Inhalte produzierst.
Na, man könnte auch ADSL sagen.
Genau.
Also das ist heute mal noch genau das Gleiche. Es hält mich auch extrem davon ab, Inhalte zu produzieren.
Eben, das ist halt kaputt und bei Bildschirmtext war es noch extremer. Die Teilnehmer waren aufgeteilt in Anbieterkennung und Teilnehmerkennung. Und ohne eine Anbieterkennung konntest du überhaupt nichts publizieren. Das hat uns natürlich nicht besonders gut gefallen. Aber eigentlich wolltest du auch was anderes hinaus. Nämlich, wie war denn das mit dem Hack?
Na ja gut, aber man muss ja erstmal beschreiben, was Bildschirmtext war. Das kennt ja heutzutage kein Mensch mehr. Das ist ja auch abgeschaltet und gibt es nicht mehr. Das ist ja nur noch so eine romantische... Früher gab es das ja mal.
Vielleicht gibt es inzwischen einen Emulator dafür. Ich weiß es nicht.
Gibt es bestimmt. Wir können ja BTX irgendwann noch mal komplett neu aufsetzen, sozusagen als virtuelles Netz auf dem Internet. Aber es war jetzt von der User Experience her, das hatte so Hyperlinks, auch wenn das nur Zahlen waren. Und es hatte so das Prinzip einer Seite. Und man kann ja auch nicht sagen, dass es jetzt unerfolgreich gewesen ist, weil es gab ja dann immerhin schon mal so Online-Banking. Das war dann so ziemlich auch das Einzige, was die Leute damit gemacht haben, aber das ist ja nun auch rechtigt.
Ja, das ist deswegen wahrscheinlich, weil die Auflösung für Porn zu schlecht war.
Wobei, da gab es also ganz netten ASCII-Porn.
Ja, ich meine, das reißt ja nichts.
Du weißt doch, wie das ist bei Porn. Das ist all about fantasy.
Okay, ja klar, sicher. Ja.
Gut, aber das hat euch jetzt nicht so beschäftigt. Ja, und der CCC war dann aber selber Anbieter.
Na, wir haben natürlich sofort als allererstes uns eine Anbieterkennung besorgt, das ist ja wohl klar.
Und, was musste man dafür tun?
Na, zahlen in erster Linie. Man musste zahlen und man brauchte ungeheuer teure Editier-Decoder. Also, wie hießen die mal noch? Also, es gab halt auch bei den Gerätschaften, gab es halt das Teilnehmer-Equipment. Das waren so Teile, mit denen konnte man halt nur angucken. Und viele davon hatten noch nicht mal eine Alpha-Tastatur. Also, wenn du deinen Namen schreiben wolltest, dann musstest du das so à la SMS machen. Und dann gab es eben diese Editier-Stationen, also so die Anbieterdekoder, und die waren praktisch fast unbezahlbar. Die waren irrsinnig teuer.
Ja.
Und der erste Hack war halt, dass wir einen Teilnehmer-Dekoder umgebaut haben in einen Anbieterdekoder, in dem wir einfach in die Tastatur, beziehungsweise, ich weiß gar nicht mehr, wer das damals gemacht hat. Ich selber habe die Löcher nicht gebohrt. Ich glaube, Steffen hat sie gebohrt. Hat mit der Bohrmaschine da, wo die Editiertasten in der Terminal-Tastatur hätten sein sollen, hat er Löcher reingebohrt und so kleine Tasten. Denn da drunter, die Elektronik da drunter, die war da. Man hat nur in der Tastatur oben die Knöpfe weggelassen.
Das heißt, ihr habt erst mal die Knöpfe nachgerüstet.
Wir haben erst mal die Knöpfe nachgerüstet mit Bohrmaschine und so Taster, die dann eben auf diese Folie da unten drauf drücken. Und wupp hatten wir eine Editierstation. Das war dieser Löwedekoder, der auch oft im Fernsehen erschienen ist. Das war eigentlich ein Teilnehmer-Dekoder. Ja, und den hat man einfach durch per Bohrmaschine und auseinandergefrickelten Tasten in einen Editier-Dekoder umgebaut. Und damit haben wir dann unsere Seiten gestaltet.
War das dann eigentlich schon Stern CCC Raute?
Das war Stern 65321 Raute.
Genau.
Stern 65321.
Nee, 65531.
Nee, weil es eine 5-stellige war.
65321.
Also eigentlich die abgekürzte 65531, die Häftlingskennung von Alex aus A Clockwork Orange. Und das hat damals, als ich ja zum Club kam, Anfang der 90er, und eben so ein bisschen diese ersten 10 Jahre dann auch verfolgt habe, was ist da passiert, was lief da ab, schon den Club auch gekennzeichnet, dass immer mit sehr viel Humor und auch mit Seitenhieben rangegangen ist, um eben dieses Verhältnis des Einzelnen gegen diesen übermächtigen Apparat, in dem Fall ja auch sogar einen staatlichen Apparat, liebevoll zu charakterisieren, um eben auch zu zeigen, na, wir sticheln hier. Und es ging immer ja um Selbstermächtigung. Im konkreten Beispiel durch das Anbohren einer Tastatur, sich selbst zu ermächtigen, Anbieterinhalte eingeben zu können, ohne sich das Gerät kaufen zu müssen. Und ich denke, das zieht sich wie eine rote Faden durch die Geschichte des Klubs, dass es immer darum ging, wie kann man Technologie so nutzen, wie sie nicht intendiert ist und damit andere Effekte erzielen, die man erreichen möchte. Und das passt ja hier auch ganz gut in die Ars Electronica, wenn man sieht, was für Ermächtigungstechnologien inzwischen dem Bürger zur Verfügung stehen. Und wenn es eine schlichte Videokamera ist, und wenn es ein Maker-Bot ist, das geht ja von Consumer-Elektronik bis zu Selbstgebauten, dass man diese Technologie in einer Art und Weise nutzen kann, wie sie möglicherweise der Hersteller, der Vertrieb oder der staatliche Rahmengeber nicht intendiert hat. Und das hat ja immer auch zu Konflikten geführt, die wir später dann auch zum Beispiel als Lobbygruppe ausgetragen haben, zu sehen, welche unintendierten Anwendungen gibt es und wie können wir sicherstellen, dass sie legal sind.
Man hat uns damals gerne mal artypisches Nutzerverhalten vorgeworfen. Naja, und wenn mich dann jemand gefragt hat, was ist eigentlich ein Hacker, dann habe ich versucht, eine Erklärung dafür zu finden. Und eigentlich die beste Erklärung, die mir eingefallen ist, ist, dass das jemand ist, der einen Fehler nur einmal durch Zufall macht und fortan absichtlich.
Ja, das trifft es glaube ich ganz gut. Das kenne ich auch immer so, dass wenn man befragt wird, vor allem nachdem man immer irgendwas getan hat, wie seid ihr denn darauf gekommen?
Blöde Frage.
Oder noch besser die Frage, wie kommt man denn auf sowas?
Ja, genau.
Ein gutes Beispiel ist auch immer so Blinken-Lights. Oh, was, ihr habt jetzt so Lampen hinter die Fenster und so. Mit Telefon, wie kommt man denn auf so eine Idee? Und dann hab ich immer nur gesagt, ja, wie bitte kommt man denn nicht auf so eine Idee? Das ist doch irgendwie total obvious. Das ist vollkommen normal. Aber es ist halt eigentlich auch wegen dieser Hacker-Kultur so ein bisschen angelegt, dass man dann eben einfach permanent, ja, also passend zu dem atypischen Nutzerverhalten, auch so ein bisschen atypisches Experimentiergehabe an den Tag legt und dann irgendwie eigentlich immer erst mal von dem Unerwarteten auch ausgeht.
Es ist ja eine Lebenseinstellung im Grunde genommen. Entweder man ist das oder man ist das nicht. Also ich glaube nicht, also manche Leute denken ja, sie können in die Schule gehen und lernen, wie werde ich ein Hacker und das funktioniert einfach nicht. Entweder man ist so gestrickt oder man ist nicht so gestrickt. Und man kann sich auch inspirieren lassen, sage ich mal. Also was man eigentlich braucht, ist Inspiration. Man braucht jetzt nicht, es gibt jetzt nicht die TU-Hackerfahrschule oder so etwas, wo man das lernen kann, wie man Hacker wird. Entweder man spürt die Inspiration oder man spürt sie nicht.
Und die spannende Frage ist dann eher, was sind die Fertigkeiten und Fähigkeiten, die man mitbringen muss, um daraus etwas zu machen. Und das ist ja auch wieder, um ein bisschen auf die Kunst zurückzukommen, ähnlich. Natürlich ist es hilfreich, wenn man mit Werkstoffen umgehen kann, wenn man Materialbeschaffenheit kennt, wenn man weiß, wie man Fertigungstechnologien einsetzt, umsetzt, wie man sie verändert, mit welchem Material man das möglichst billig zum Beispiel erreichen kann, wenn man halt keine Finanzierung hat. Also ich finde immer das Makerboard-Beispiel sehr gut, was man damit erreichen kann mit ein bisschen Abfallkunststoff. Und letztlich war es das ja auch im Club immer. Ich habe als Kind gerne mit Lego gespielt. Ich bin ja westlich des Eisen und Vorhangs aufgewachsen, also das große Glück. Und es gab immer Kinder, die haben versucht, aus diesen Lego-Steinen etwas zu bauen, was auf der Abbildung der Schachtel war, damit es so aussieht, wie das, was auf der Abbildung der Schachtel war. Und ich wollte einfach sehen, was kann man aus diesen Steinen zusammensetzen. Und das war letztlich immer auch etwas, was ich im Club wiedergefunden habe, dass da so ein spielerisches Entdecken war, aus den Bausteinen, die man zur Verfügung hat, einem Mikroprozessor, einem Haufen Lötzinn, einer Fotodiode und einer guten Idee. Und daraus sich aber eben auch Kreativität entwickelt hat, zu sehen, mit dem gegebenen Material, was kann ich damit erzielen. Und das auch sicherlich dazu geführt hat, dass so ein systemanalytisches Verständnis gekommen ist, bei den meisten, die sich im Clubumfeld oder überhaupt in der Hacker-Szene und dann in Teilen ja auch in der Kunstszene bewegen, was da ein Verständnis da ist. Wie ist das System beschaffen? Was ist der mir vorgegebene Rahmen? Was sind meine Instrumente? Und wie kann ich mit diesen den Rahmen sprengen? Kunst sprengt ja auch immer den Rahmen auf und zeigt auf, wie geht es denn weiter? Was kann ich denn über das Intendierte hinaus tun? Wie kann ich Veränderungen erzielen? Und wenn es nur Veränderungen im Denken ist. Und ich denke, das war auch immer ein Weg der Hacker-Szene. Man denkt halt außerhalb der Schachtel. Und man hat Instrumente. Und wie kann man damit etwas erzielen? Wie kann man mit einem Stück Klorolle und ein bisschen Lötzubehör, ein paar Kabel, einen Akustikkoppler bauen, den man eigentlich nicht besitzen dürfte, um eben diese vorgegebene Beschränkung, diese Asymmetrie aufzuheben, das immer vorgegeben ist. Es gibt dieses klassische Medienmodell. Es gibt die klassische Senderichtung von den großen privaten Anbietern, die der Staat zulässt, und den großen staatlichen Institutionen.
Und du als Verbraucher sollst nur die Klappe halten? Und konsumieren. Und das widerstrebt, glaube ich, jedem von uns schon immer.
Also das war ja auch letztlich Bildschirmtext, um das nochmal für diejenigen zu erläutern, die es nicht kennen. Sieht aus wie Videotext, was vermutlich die meisten noch kennen. Also Textinhalte im Fernsehen. Nur, dass der Rückkanal besteht, in dem man Ja, Nein und Kaufen sagen konnte. Und das einfach allen widerstrebte, zu sagen, ich möchte Inhalte ja nicht konsumieren. Ich möchte sie remixen. Ich möchte das, was heute als Remix-Kultur, was durch die Creative Commons dann auch wieder in ein legales Umfeld eingebettet wird, dass das möglich gemacht wird. Und das ist, denke ich, auch wieder ein schönes Beispiel zu sehen, wo diese Schnittstellen in die wirkliche Welt sind. Denn natürlich spielt man als Kind gerne mit dem Lego auch mal ein paar Stunden lang versunken von der Außenwelt entfernt. Und genauso spielt man als Hacker mal eine Nacht lang mit irgendwelchen Geräten völlig versunken von der Wirklichkeit und stellt irgendwann fest, dass die letzte Bahn weg ist und man halt nochmal vier Stunden spielt, bis die erste wieder fährt. Und dann aber eben auch diese Einbindung in einen immer größeren Kontext passiert ist, was ja anfangs sehr konfliktbehaftet war, dass eben Hausdurchsuchungen kamen, dass das Anschließen eines Modems in Deutschland härter bestraft war als die Herbeiführung einer Kernexplosion, was sich viele Leute ja zu Hause aufgehoben haben, eingerahmt ihren Haftbefehl wegen Anschließen eines Modems an die Telefonleitung. Dass das dann ja auch gezeigt hat, na gut, wie können wir denn als Kreative, wie können wir denn als Systemanalytiker, wie können wir als Juristen, wie können wir diese Szene erweitern, dass wir uns mit Leuten außerhalb unseres sehr engen Kontexts zusammenschließen, um zu sagen, wir wollen die Welt transformieren und welche Pfade gibt es, welche Pfadeabhängigkeiten gibt es und wo müssen wir es möglicherweise einfach aufbrechen.
War denn diese Transformationsidee Vic, war denn das eigentlich damals, so in den ersten Tagen des Clubs, war denn das wirklich so das beherrschende Grundgefühl oder war das eigentlich alles nur so aus der Aktion und dem Spaß am Gerät heraus? Also jetzt gerade diese BTX-Nummer, ich meine, ich kann das natürlich verstehen, da ist dann so ein Netz, das will man dann einfach mal benutzen und kennenlernen und in seinem Wesen auseinanderklambüsern, aber schwebt da jetzt in irgendeiner Form schon so die Botschaft mit im Raum, für die der Club dann in der Folge bekannt geworden ist?
Naja, also wir waren schon immer systemkritisch, also politisch gesehen, und haben immer auch versucht, jetzt Hacks nicht nur technischer Natur herzustellen, sondern eben auch Hacks, wenn du so willst, politischer Natur. Also Hackertum ist ja nicht beschränkt auf Technik und auf Elektronik und so ein Zeug, sondern ich meine, es gab auch von Anfang an Social Engineering. Ich erinnere mich noch, dass mal jemand durch Telefonieren die Kennung von dem damaligen FTZ, also von dem Fernmeldetechnischen Zentralamt, von dem Chef den Usernamen und das Kennwort rausgekriegt hat.
Für das BTX-System.
Genau, einfach nur durch Anrufen.
Der hat einfach gefragt.
Na was heißt gefragt? Also sich einfach eine irgendeine irre Geschichte ausgedacht und alle möglichen Leute angerufen, bis er diese Kennung in der Hand hatte.
Guten Tag, Qualitätssicherung.
Genau, auf die Art. Natürlich macht Spaß am Gerät, war auch immer eine Triebfeder. Aber es gab eben auch andere Disziplinen und es gab auch Leute, die überhaupt nichts mit Technik zu tun hatten und die einfach die Idee cool fanden und einfach irgendwas gemacht haben mit den Mitteln, die sie zur Verfügung hatten. Und es gab ja auch immer schon eigentlich die weltweite, wie soll ich sagen, dieser weltweite Hacker-Consens. Es gab ja zu der Zeit auch schon TAP und 2600 und Youth International Party Line und was weiß ich. Das war im Grunde genommen eine Bewegung, die musste kommen, zwangsweise. Es war im Grunde genommen nur die Frage, wer fängt sie auf? Also ich glaube, dass das in den Menschen, also zumindest in den Kreativen, einfach dieser Wunsch drin steckte und der brauchte eigentlich nur noch einen Namen. Und dann hat Bau eines Tages halt das Wort Chaos Computer Club gesagt und hatte das einen Namen.
Wir haben ja diesen Mythos, dass der Club am 12. September 81 gegründet wurde. Das habe ich ja schon mal herausgefunden, das stimmt so nicht. Muss man aber jetzt auch trotzdem nicht unbedingt verwerfen. In Chaosradio Express 77 habe ich ja so die alten überlebende Runde, die damals an diesem Treffen teilgenommen haben, an diesen Tuvatt-Treffen teilgenommen haben. Da kam ja heraus, dass zwar im Rahmen dieses Treffens eben genau dieses Aufbruchsmoment sich eigentlich manifestiert hat, aber so konkret eben diesen Namen noch nicht hatte. Mit dem kam VAU dann später irgendwann auf. Ich habe es mittlerweile aufgegeben, da zu hoffen, dass man dieses Datum als solches nochmal... Na klar, natürlich ist es egal, aber man weiß ja, wie nerds sind. Die wollen es ja immer ganz genau wissen. Wie auch immer. Also jetzt, wie ist denn dann diese... Ach so, worauf ich hinauswolle, ist, dass aus dieser Sendung könnte man schon ganz gut herauslesen, wie das eben auch ein Kind seiner Zeit war. Die 68er, dann irgendwie die 70er, diese Terrorphase in Deutschland und dann eben dieser Druck auf diese linke aufgeklärte Szene. Oh Gott, wollen wir jetzt hier irgendwie so in der Terroristen-Ecke landen? Oder wollen wir nicht eher progressiv da voranschreiten und auch wirklich was zur Veränderung der Gesellschaft beitragen? Und ich hatte so den Eindruck gewonnen, dass eben das, was VAU da im Wesentlichen mitgebracht hat, quasi dann die elektronische Variante davon war, dass der Chaos Computer Club quasi für ihn auch ein Projekt darstellte, um dann eben diesen gesellschaftlichen Wandel im Kontext moderne Technologie voranzuführen. Würdest du dem so zustimmen?
Ja, wir haben ja dann damals auch, sage ich jetzt mal, viele so Aktivistengruppen und sowas geholfen, sich zu vernetzen, dass wir halt einfach denen gezeigt haben, wie man sowas macht. Also wie man beispielsweise, ich erinnere mich noch an, ein Beispiel war Union Carbide. Das waren halt diese, weiß ich nicht, kannst du ja nachgucken, da ging es halt um Vergiftung von Leuten durch einen US-Konzern. Und da haben sich halt verschiedenliche Aktivistengruppen auf dem ganzen Planeten zum ersten Mal halt elektronisch vernetzt. Und da haben wir halt so ein bisschen, soll ich sagen, mitgeholfen, weil wir das Zeug halt hatten. Und insofern hatte das auch immer schon eine gesellschaftliche und politische Dimension vom ersten Tag an. In dem Fall ging es da halt um, es waren halt Umweltaktivisten.
Wie ist denn dann diese Geschichte mit dem BTX eigentlich weitergegangen? Also, ich meine, CCC war dann irgendwie Anbieter. Im Gegensatz zum World Wide Web gab es ja im BTX dieses schöne Feature, dass man für das Ansehen einer Seite dann auch Geld einfordern konnte. Also, dass sozusagen der Abruf einer Seite dann automatisch mit dem Überweisen von Geld von dem einen Nutzerkonto zum anderen verbunden war. Da hatte der Club dann so eine Spendenseite für 9,99 oder so.
Ja, 9,99 war der Maximalbetrag. Und ja, man konnte eben jeden anderen Betrag auch wählen. Und allerdings sollte das eben sozusagen, weil sie sich wohl selber noch nicht ganz sicher waren, haben sie diesen Betrag halt begrenzt. Und der erschien dann bei dem Teilnehmer, der diese Seite aufgerufen hatte, auf der Telefonrechnung. Und ja, und der Andieter bekam das dann halt abzüglich der nicht ganz unwesentlichen Postbearbeitungsgebühr dann halt gut geschrieben. Und davon hat das System gelebt.
Also ich meine, gab es da irgendjemand, der diese Spendenseite wirklich...
Oh ja, da gab es doch durchaus einige, die die aufgerufen haben. Allerdings, also es war ja nicht eine Spendenseite, sondern wir haben so ein kleines Filmchen. Also es hieß ursprünglich, BTX geht nur statisch. Das heißt, man kann nur eine Seite anzeigen und vielleicht, man konnte es bestenfalls ein bisschen blinken lassen. Und wir sind halt irgendwann, also Steffen im Wesentlichen, weil er sich damit am meisten beschäftigt hatte. Er hat irgendwie Tag und Nacht an diesem aufgebohrten Decoder gesessen und ist dann auf die Idee gekommen, wie man tatsächlich damit dynamische Inhalte erzeugen kann. Das heißt, er hat dann sozusagen auch schon wieder als Beweis, man kann doch dynamische Inhalte machen, hat er halt ein Filmchen gebaut. Und in diesem Filmchen, da gab es so ein kleines Raumschiff und so Posthörnchen und da flogen da so Posthörnchen und dieses Raumschiff kam und schoss die Posthörnchen ab und die explodierten.
Hatte das nicht auch noch einen netten Namen?
Nuki, glaube ich, hieß es.
Was, das Raumschiff?
Ich kann mir das alles nicht mehr merken, ich erinnere mich eben auch nur an die Eckpunkte nach so vielen Jahren. Aber auf jeden Fall kam da halt das kleine Raumschiff und schoss Posthörnchen ab.
Also man kriegt da auch was für sein Geld.
Ja, selbstverständlich. Naja, und dieses Filmchen, das wurde doch einige Male abgerufen, weil das war eben praktisch der einzige dynamische Inhalt im BTX.
Ja.
Und es war insofern eben auch noch ganz witzig, weil eben das BTX ja von der Bundespost war. Und eben so auch noch, wie der Andreas schon sagte, so ein kleiner Seitenhieb auf die Post eben, dass da Posthörnchen abgeschossen werden und explodieren. Das war ja halt das Symbol der Bundespost. Naja, und dann, und bei eben gerade bei diesem Editieren dieser dynamischen Inhalte, da sind wir auch überall, oder ist, also da hab ich jetzt nicht so, da hab ich, an dem hab ich nicht mitgewirkt, ist eben auch der Steffen über einige Fehler gestolpert, die das System hatte. Also die praktisch dieser Zentralrechner, das war ja komplett zentralistisch.
Alle Inhalte waren sozusagen auf einem System?
Auf einem einzigen großen Computer, den glaube ich IBM da hingestellt hat, in ein Hochhaus in Ulm. Den haben wir früher immer das Ulmer Muttertier genannt. Und da war das alles drin. Und das war halt, der hat dann halt die ganze Geschichte da verwaltet. Alle Teilnehmerabfragen, alle Editierzugänge, alles einfach. Und der war eben, wie wir ja heute auch, wie heute jeder weiß, ist Software nie fehlerfrei. Und auch dieser Rechner hat eine ganze Menge Fehler gehabt. Einige führten halt dazu, dass wahllos Inhalte des Speichers plötzlich auf deinem Schirm erschienen.
So eine Art Buffer-Overflow, und dann hat sich das alles so in den eigenen Bildschirm erbrochen.
Genau, richtig.
Und dann erbrach sich eine Kennung.
Da sind eben auch Kennungen dabei gewesen, also Teilnehmerkennungen.
Mit Kennwörtern.
Ja, mit Kennwörtern.
Die nicht verschlüsselt waren.
Natürlich nicht. Zu der Zeit, ich bitte, die Verschlüsselung, ich weiß gar nicht.
Naja, muss man ja mal hinweisen.
Wozu auch? Das ist ja das klassische staatliche Modell. Es hat ja ohnehin nur der Zugriff, der berechtigt ist, und damit was soll da schon schiefgehen?
So, und um die Geschichte dann nochmal rund zu machen, da war dann eine Kennung von einer, von ausgerechnet von der Hamburger Sparkasse dann dabei.
Genau.
Also sozusagen die Nachbarschaft.
Weil der Club ja in Hamburg war.
Genau. Ja, und die hat man dann halt, wie soll ich sagen, man hat, also diese Dekoder waren auch noch so, die waren also total sicher. Die hatten nämlich einen ROM drin, wo eine zwölfstellige Anschlusskennung drin gespeichert war. Und nur mit dieser Anschlusskennung konnte man eben auch gebührenpflichtige Seiten aufrufen. Und das war eben nur in genau einem Modem, in einem versiegelten und verschlossenen Modem waren diese Kennungen halt so in Proms oder so gespeichert. Und ohne die konnte man halt diese Kennung auch gar nicht benutzen. Dann brauchte man eben noch die Benutzerkennung.
Also man konnte die Kennung schon benutzen, aber nicht um Geld.
Na du brauchstest das Modem. Du brauchstest im Prinzip das Modem des Teilnehmers, damit du irgendwie...
Ach so, der Haspa, nur da hat dieser Login funktioniert. Okay, das ist ja schon mal ein Security-Feature.
Genau, die Anschlusskennung war dem Anschluss fest zugeordnet und kann natürlich nur von Posttechnikern dort eingebracht werden. Und weil die natürlich nicht korrupt sind oder bestechlich oder keine Fehler machen, ist das System sicher.
Das sind ja Beamte, ne?
Damit ist auch klar, wenn so eine Kennung auftaucht, dann ist es von diesem Anschluss zugeordnet, die Kommunikation, was natürlich für staatliche Überwachungsmaßnahmen notwendig ist im Zweifel oder für die Rechnungslegung. Und was wir auch später gesehen haben, zum Beispiel bei Faxgeräten, wo das der Fall war, Fernkopie war dann ja auch eine spannende Technologie der 80er Jahre, die natürlich nur ausgewählte Teilnehmer gegen teuer Geld nutzen konnten, weil man versucht hat, möglichst viel Profit aus dem zu schlagen. Und ja, weil es ohnehin nur in staatlicher Hand war, keinerlei Wettbewerb bestand und somit auch die Preise dektiert werden konnten. Und dort natürlich die Anschlusskennung fest eingetragen war, was lange Zeit dazu geführt hat, dass Bekenner-Schreiben der RAF zum Beispiel von der Redaktion des Spiegel kamen, weil offensichtlich die Terroristen in der Lage waren, die Faxkennung zu verändern. Und die Frage ist, waren sie Terroristen, weil sie die Faxkennung verändert haben oder andersrum? Und das ist so ein Faden, der sich bis heute durchzieht, dass der Staat immer wieder versucht, eine eindeutige Zuordnung zu schaffen zum Teilnehmer und zu regulieren, was kann sich der Nutzer ansehen, was darf sich der Nutzer ansehen?
Aktuelles Beispiel sind halt die Prepaid-Telefonkarten. Die kriegt man heute auch praktisch nirgendwo mehr ohne einen Pass zu zeigen.
Oder künftig eben der Wunsch, dass der Zugang zum Internet nur mehr möglich sein soll mit dem elektronischen Personalausweis, der dann eine entsprechende Chip erhält und dann eben auch als Bezahlinstrument genutzt werden kann, damit kein Bestellmissbrauch im Internet mehr stattfindet. Und den schönen Nebeneffekt hat, dass eine staatliche, flächige Kontrolle möglich ist. Wer nutzt denn das Internet? Wer fragt den, welche Seiten ab? Und damit dann eben auch sehr detaillierte Personenprofile erzeugt werden können. Das war ja schon von Anfang an in der Technik immer angelegt, dass also die Begleitumstände der Telekommunikation protokolliert werden können. Dass also nachvollziehbar ist, wer eine Seite abgerufen hat. Zunächst zur Abrechnungszweck. Und da kommen wir gleich nochmal drauf, wenn wir die Geschichte des Hacks dann fertig erzählen. Und dass aber bis heute eben so wie ein roter Faden sich durchzieht, dass der Staat immer versucht, das möglichst zu kontrollieren, möglichst einzuschränken, möglichst zu verhindern. Und das ja immer die Auseinandersetzung war, die der Club gelebt hat. Neophile Menschen, die Technologie in nichtintendierter Weise nutzen wollten. Art typisches Nutzerverhalten. Und auf der anderen Seite so ein monolithischer, staatlicher Überbau, der versucht hat, das zu begrenzen. Und ich denke, das ist ja auch genau die Auseinandersetzung, die wir jetzt gerade wieder sehen. Dass die Staaten der Erde mit freier Kommunikation nicht umgehen können, Angst davor haben, Unverständnis bei den politischen Entscheidungsträgern herrscht. Und damit versucht wird, über das Instrumentarium zu verbieten, zu regulieren, zu verhindern. Versucht wird, Wachstumsprozesse, Veränderungsprozesse, Transformationen einzugrenzen, zu entschleunigen und handhabbar zu machen in den Verwaltungen. Wobei man eben auch sehen muss, dass diese maroden Administrationen offensichtlich nicht geeignet sind, diesen Transformationsprozess mitzumachen. Und das ja auch sehr viele Teilnehmer am Netz inzwischen begreifen. Und dann halt auch Abitrage spielen über Jurisdiktionen hinweg und sagen, na gut, dann spielen wir halt die Globalisierung mal zum Vorteil der Bürger aus und nicht immer nur gegen uns. Wie wir das ja hier in der Tabakfabrik erleben, dieser Ort ist uns ja nur ermöglicht worden, weil die vorherigen Eigentümer offensichtlich gesagt haben, die Rendite sei nicht hoch genug und die Fabrikation geschlossen und verlagert haben. Und Globalisierung sich ja ganz oft manifestiert als etwas Negatives in der individuellen Erfahrung. Und aber dann eben auch erkämpft werden muss, welche positiven Effekte das hat. Da gehört sicherlich die Reisefreiheit dazu, dass es also sehr viel einfacher geworden ist, den Planeten zu sehen. Und eben auch die Kommunikationsfreiheit, dass wir in der Lage sind, mit Menschen um den Globus herum uns frei auszutauschen. Und das ist, denke ich, der Kampf, den wir gerade führen, um zu verhindern, dass das unterbunden wird. Und wenn es dazu möglich ist, eben verschiedene Rechtsräume zu nutzen, dann denke ich, ist das auch ein Spiel, was der Club ja immer gespielt hat, zu sagen, dann schieben wir den Schwarzen Peter um den Erdball und wir spielen so ein bisschen Fang.
Vielleicht sollte man es digitale Reisefreiheit nennen, dann würden die Leute wahrscheinlich freie weltweite Kommunikation ganz anders auffassen. Ja, das Datenreisen, das ist ja eigentlich auch so ein Begriff, den der Club schon seit Urzeiten mit sich mitschleppt. Seit wann gibt es den denn?
Na ja, damals waren eben auch die einzigen existierenden Datennetze eben auch zentralistisch organisiert. Es gab schon Datennetze. Es gab auch in den 80ern schon ein Paketvermitteltes Datennetz. Das Internet ist ja auch ein Paketvermitteltes Datennetz im Grunde genommen. Und das gab es halt in zentralistischer Form für unglaublich teuer, für unglaublich wenige ausgesuchte, meist industrielle. Das hieß halt Datex P. Das war die deutsche Variante von dem X25-Netz. Das lief damals noch mit X25-Protokoll. Da haben wir uns natürlich auch sehr frühzeitig mit beschäftigt. Das war eben wirklich schweinisch teuer. Wir haben auch zum Teil die Kennungen von großzügigen, großen Konzernen ausgeliehen, zuweilen auch ohne deren Wissen.
Die haben das sozusagen gefördert.
Die haben das sozusagen gefördert. Dieses X25-Netz war eben schon damals grundsätzlich international ausgelegt, sodass man damit eben auch schon mal einen Link in die Staaten hatte und wohin auch immer und nach England und in die Forschungsinstitutionen. Da die Forschungsinstitutionen eben damals schon über diese verschiedenen anderen Netze verbunden waren, hat man die quasi als Backbone mitbenutzt, von denen, die allerdings auch nicht immer was wussten.
Und sich dort natürlich auch im Zweifel Kopien von Software verschafft, die dort für die Angehörigen der Forschungsinstitutionen und die jene an sie angeschlossenen Teilnehmer verfügbar waren. Und letztlich ist das ja, wenn man sich diese Geschichte ansieht, und auch die Art und Weise, wie das strafbewehrt war und wie dann auch die Verfolgung stattgefunden hat. Also dieser, sind wir dann zwei Jahre schon nach dem BTX-Hack, dieser größte Spionageskandal seit Gintergium. Letztlich haben die da ja nichts anderes gemacht, als das Internet zu surfen und sich Software zu holen.
Du sprichst jetzt den KGB-Hack an, ne?
Aber das hat mich halt retrospektiv so fasziniert. Als ich das damals sah, mit irgendwie acht, neun, zehn, war das halt ein Vorgang, der stattgefunden hat, der damals noch auch massenmedial vermittelt tatsächlich ja aussah, wie organisiertes Verbrechen, wie Straftäter, wie nachrichtendienstliches Handeln. Und je älter ich wurde und je mehr ich verstand, was da passiert ist, habe ich gesehen, die wollten halt das Internet surfen. Und man hat es ihnen nicht erlaubt. Und man hat die Voraussetzungen nicht geschafft, weil die Administrationen immer den Wunsch hatten, möglichst viel Profit zu schlagen, möglichst einzugrenzen, zu kontrollieren und auch sozusagen zu lizensieren, wenn auch zunächst natürlich nur über den Preis, über die Anbieterkennung, wer Inhalte bereitstellen darf. Und im Club immer angelegt war ja auch schon der Präambel, dass es ein Menschenrecht auf frei ungehinderte, mindestens weltweite Kommunikation geben muss. Und nur so auch diese nationalen Transformationsprozesse irgendwie durchgeführt werden können, wenn man darauf beruht, ja auch Demokratie auf dem freien Austausch der Meinungen und letztlich auch dem freien Wettbewerb der Meinungen. Und das sich ja dann auch gezeigt hat, wie eng das verknüpft war zwischen dem Sozialen und dem Technischen und Technologischen. Ich war mit meinen Eltern in Moskau kurz vor dem Putsch. Und als wir aus Moskau zurückkamen, gab es kurze Nacht den Putsch. Und die Putschisten hatten alle Telefonleitungen gehabt, alle Telex-Leitungen.
Welchen Putsch meinst du jetzt?
91 gegen Gorbatschow. Ja. Alle Leitungen wurden gehabt. Also die Fernemt, das war eine hierarchisch zentralisierte Pyramidenstruktur. Und nur an der Spitze der Pyramide gab es überhaupt Kommunikation ins Ausland und dann insbesondere auch ins westliche Ausland. Und die Leitungen wurden allesamt gekappt, weil es, das war ja auch möglich, weil es eben ein zentralistisches pyramidales System war. Man an einer Stelle wusste, wenn ich hier schneide, ist die Kommunikation unterbunden und die freie Kommunikation nicht mehr möglich. Und auf der anderen Seite gab es ja aber in wenigen Forschungseinrichtungen und Unis auch damals schon Internetanschlüsse und Paketvermittel des Netzs. Auch dort wurde versucht, die Leitungen zu kappen. Nichtsdestotrotz gab es aber immer noch Leitungen und das Routing, also die algorithmische Art und Weise, einen Weg für das Paket zu finden, hat ja so gut funktioniert, dass trotzdem Kommunikation nach außen möglich war, obwohl eine militärische Struktur versucht hat, das zu unterbinden. Und einer der ersten, die damals auch diese Kommunikation mitgenommen haben, waren Leute in Finnland, weil die einfach Angst hatten und versucht haben, herauszufinden, was passiert denn da. Na die haben halt versucht, mit Mailboxen zu kommunizieren, mit Leuten im Land, um herauszufinden, was ist hier eigentlich passiert. Julf Helsingius, der später den Pnet-Remailer, einen der ersten Anonymisierer für E-Mail betrieben hat, meinte, das war so sein Erweckungserlebnis zu verstehen, was diese Kommunikation ist. Und Vau meinte immer, für ihn war das Tschernobyl. Dass in den westlichen Medien die Ansage war, in Schweden ist offensichtlich irgendwas passiert, wir wissen nicht was, aber es gibt radioaktiven Fallout. Und Vau meinte, er hat in der Zeit halt mit Leuten über Mailbox-Netze kommuniziert, die ihm vor Ort Berichte gaben und meint, na offensichtlich ist es ein Stück nach Süden in der Ukraine. Und dass das also, obwohl ja ganz offensichtlich massive Interessen in dem Fall einer Supermacht berührt waren, die versuchten das zu unterbinden, hat die Technik es auch ermöglicht, diese Kommunikation durchzuführen. Und ich denke da immer an die Eröffnungsrede der Funkausstellung in Berlin durch Albert Einstein, der meinte, bedenkt aber, dass es die Techniker sind, die wahre Demokratie erst möglich machen werden. Und das war was, was im Club für mich immer angelegt war, dass da Menschen waren, die gesagt haben, okay, wir haben hier ein technisches Interesse, wir spielen mit diesen kleinen Lego-Steinchen und freuen uns drüber, aber schau, wenn wir es fertig haben, gibt es Leute, die sich dafür interessieren und wir geben es ihnen. Und ich habe das oft erlebt, wenn wir Infrastruktur bereitgestellt haben für Dritte, dass die Frage kam, warum tut ihr das? Und meine Antwort war eigentlich immer, weil wir es können. Und das war halt auch so ein Schritt, dass man gesagt hat, na gut, wir können das, andere benötigen das. Warum sollen wir es nicht bereitstellen? Also sei es verschlüsselte Mailing-Listen für Umweltaktivisten, sei es irgendwie Mailbox-Systeme für Menschenrechtsgruppen, all das, was ja auch bis heute wie ein roter Faden durch die Clubgeschichte geht, dass wir immer auch versuchen, Dritten diese Infrastruktur bereitzustellen und zu sagen, wir sind zwar Techniker und wir können nur dieses eine Ding, aber das können wir sehr gut. Und ihr macht wieder was anderes aus diesen Bausteinen.
Die, bevor wir jetzt zu weit vorgreifen, noch ein kurzer Hinweis, also diese Sache mit DatXP, KGB, HAK, diese Zeit, kann ich auch noch mal auf eine andere Ausgabe von CRE hinweisen. Chaosradio Express 100.
Das Wichtigste aus der Zeit ist eigentlich ganz was anderes. Wir haben nämlich damals...
Lass mich das mal kurz erwähnen. Da hatte ich mich ja mit Hans unterhalten, genau über die Zeit. Da werden wir jetzt nicht noch mit reinkommen. Was wolltest du jetzt sagen?
Na, ich wollte sagen, eigentlich für mich war das aus der Zeit, dass die Hauptentwicklung, die wir damals gemacht haben, ist, dass wir auf den Kisten, die wir aufgemacht haben, in den Forschungsinstitutionen, da haben wir ein Chat-System installiert. Das war sozusagen... Man hat sich sozusagen beim Hacken unterhalten. Und so ist es zu einem Chat-System gekommen. Wir haben damals dieses Fineas in DCL geschrieben. Ich glaube, das ist auch irgendwo in der Hackerbibel abgedruckt. Leider mit Druckfehlern.
Was ist Fineas?
Na, das ist ein Chat-System, was wir geschrieben haben, was auf einer Wechsel läuft.
Im VMS Betriebssystem?
Im DCL praktisch. Das war damals die Shell von VMS. Quasi, also so wie eine Art Shell-Sprache von VMS. Und da drin haben wir halt ein Chat-System zusammengehackt. Und haben halt dann eben auf diesen Maschinen, die wir halt aufgemacht hatten, und das waren ja zahllose, über den ganzen Planeten verteilt, die haben wir in erster Linie als Chatserver benutzt.
Weil es ja sonst keine gab.
Eben. Und das war sozusagen die Geburtsstunde unseres Chats.
Hat so ein bisschen was von Backpackers-Reisen, wo man dann auch mal einen Backpacker aufschlägt mit seinem Rucksack und dann sich erst mal mit den anderen Travelern austauscht über die Orte, wo man noch so hingehen könnte.
Genau. Und das passt eben auch zum Thema Datenreisen. Wir haben uns da natürlich auch darüber ausgetauscht. Und wenn du über das Netz und jenen Gateway gehst, dann kommst du da hin und da kannst du die Kiste so aufmachen. Und da haben wir schon ein kleines Programmchen installiert. Da kann man sich unsichtbar machen. Und dann gehst du weiter nach da und so. Und so ging das halt.
Ja, das ist ja die zweite Hälfte der 80er-Jahre, wenn ich das jetzt richtig sehe, wo das irgendwie richtig losging. Jetzt will ich dann nochmal kurz zurückblättern nochmal auf diese BTX-Geschichte, weil die war ja dann auch für den Club ein sehr prägendes Ereignis. Ihr habt also sozusagen diese Spendenseite da gehabt und dieses Angebot da gehabt und dieses Filmchen gezeigt. Und durch diese Fehlererkennung sozusagen, also durch diese Datenabscheidung, die dieser Zentralrechner in den eigenen Bildschirm hineingors, hatte man also jetzt diesen Zugang von der Hamburger Sparkasse bekommen. Aber du hast ja erwähnt, man konnte den ja eigentlich gar nicht nutzen, wenn man nicht auch das entsprechende Modem hatte.
Genau, aber wir haben dann eben festgestellt, dass wenn man ein Modem einfach, wenn man dieses Prom mit der Anschlusskennung einfach rausgerissen hat, dann funktionierte dieses Modem quasi als Testmodem und dann konnte man sie eingeben.
Super.
Das heißt also, mit einem...
Also es ist einfach ein atypisches Benutzerverhalten an den Tag gelegt sozusagen.
Naja, wir haben dann auch noch ein bisschen weitergeforscht und haben festgestellt, wenn man den typischen CCITT-Standard für 1200 zu 75 auf irgendein Modem gefahren hat, dass das Ding dann immer nach der Anschlusskennung gefragt hat. Das war offensichtlich in der Software so implementiert, dass man dann, wenn man einen Modem oder Akustikkoppler oder whatever hatte, was keine automatische Anschlusskennung gesendet hat, hat das Ding einfach gefragt.
Ah, super. Das heißt, dann habt ihr es einfach eingegeben und dann wart ihr die Hasbar.
Genau.
Und dann?
Naja, und dann war natürlich das Problem, man konnte eben nur 9,99. Man brauchte mehrere Tastendrücke.
Ja, Moment, aber was war denn jetzt bitte, ich meine, was ging euch denn als erstes durch den Kopf, als ihr dieses Login hatte?
Naja, erst mal, das ging natürlich, hat sich ja alles über im Grunde genommen Tage, Wochen hingezogen und man versucht natürlich irgendwie, sich auch zu überlegen, was kann man denn damit für einen Unfug anstellen? Das ist ja ganz klar.
Ja.
Also was kann man Witziges damit machen? Und was uns dann eben eingefallen ist, wenn man jetzt eben unsere Anbieterseite damit oft aufrufen würde, dann könnte man ganz schön große Zahlen damit erzeugen.
Also die 99-Mark-Seite.
Genau.
5 Euro pro Klick.
Genau. Aber das war ja sehr langsam. Du musstest ja dann erst die Seitennummer aufrufen, dann musstest du die Rautetaste drücken. Da hat dich das Ding gefragt, bist du wirklich sicher? Achtung, das kostet 99-Mark-Seite. Dann musstest du glaube ich nochmal die Rautetaste drücken.
Die 2 für ja. Die 2 war die ja. Musstest du nicht bei der Ja-Nein-Abfrage mit einer 2 bestätigt haben?
Nee, mit 1,9 und 2, glaube ich. 1,9 war ja und 2 war nein.
Also noch an der 1,9 eingeben sozusagen?
Genau. Und dann die Rautetaste. Dann hat dich das Ding gefragt, willst du wirklich? Und dann musstest du nochmal die Rautetaste drücken. Und dann hat es gesagt, alles klar. Jetzt habe ich sie kassiert.
Und dann kam die Seite?
Na ja. Dann konnte man aber nochmal die Rautetaste drücken. Und dann kam wieder die Frage, willst du bezahlen? Und dann konnte man nochmal die Rautetaste drücken. Und dann hat man nochmal bezahlt.
Aber eigentlich ging es von einem sehr unmündigen Benutzer aus, dem man ständig gefragt hat, möchtest du das? Bist du dir ganz sicher? Wirklich? Ja? Also ein bisschen wie Windows Vista heute. Möchtest du wirklich? Bist du dir sicher?
Ja, Leute sowieso immer Ja sagen. Weil sie wollen, dass dieser Dialog verschwindet.
Genau. Egal. Aber auf jeden Fall war das halt so, dass man, also das ist deswegen wichtig, dass man mit Raute-Taste weitergehen konnte.
Das heißt, man musste eigentlich nur immer wieder Raute drücken, um einen konstanten Geldfluss zu erzeugen?
Genau. Also einen, wie soll ich sagen, nicht einen konstanten Geldfluss. Der ging schon etwas abrupt immer in 9 Mark 99 Schritten. Aber im Prinzip, wenn man das Timing richtig hatte, konnte man damit eine Art konstanten Geldfluss erzeugen.
Und das heißt, hat sich jemand hingesetzt und die ganze Zeit Raute gedrückt?
Na ja, das haben wir uns natürlich auch überlegt. Aber das wäre zu mühsam gewesen. Wir neigten eh schon immer, so etwas zu automatisieren. Und jetzt kommt eben dieser kleine Olivetti M10 mit dem Kassettenrekorder-Relais ins Spiel. Weil wir nämlich einfach die Tastatur ein weiteres Mal auseinander genommen haben. Zwei Drähte an die Raute-Taste angeschlossen. Und diese beiden Drähte an das Kassettenrekorder-Relais von dem Olivetti M10 angeschlossen. Und dann ein kleines Basic-Programm geschrieben, was immer die Kassette an, Kassette aus gemacht hat. Mit einem entsprechenden Timing.
Und einmal Kassette an, Kassette aus heißt, einmal die Taste gedrückt.
Genau.
Das heißt, dann hat dieses Programm quasi die ganze Zeit Raute gedrückt.
Und der BTX, das BTX-Terminal mit der eingegebenen Kennung von der Haspa, hat dann, wie lange lief das irgendwie, ein ganzes Wochenende oder so?
Nö, eine Nacht lang.
Eine Nacht nur.
Wir haben dann halt auf unserem Anbieterkonto ja nachgucken können, wie viel das ist. Und dann haben wir gesehen, oh, das sind 135.000 Mark. Na lass mal abstellen. Und dann haben wir mal abgestellt.
So, im Prinzip war jetzt sozusagen der kriminelle Hacker jetzt geboren.
Ja, was heißt kriminell? Das war ja im Grunde genommen auch nur, also es war ja, verstehst du, es war Spaß. Es war irgendwie immer ausprobieren.
Na ja gut, aber jetzt habt ihr da sozusagen mal zum Test die Bank beraubt.
So wurde es nachher in der Presse dargestellt, weil die Leute ja nichts verstehen. Es war ja so, dass wir eben als BTX-Anbieter, dass ein Teilnehmer praktisch, in dem Fall ein simulierter Teilnehmer, uns als Anbieter aufgerufen hat und die Bundespost quasi von der Telefonrechnung des Teilnehmers auf unsere Telefonrechnung umgebucht hat.
Na ja, das ist schon klar.
Damit war unsere dann deutlich im Haben.
Ja, okay, das heißt, der CCC hatte aber sozusagen die Bank erleichtert. Ich meine, es ist ja klar, dass das jeder dann so liest. Nur, man war zu dem Zeitpunkt dann der Plan, damit an die Öffentlichkeit zu gehen, quasi schon damit verbunden.
Na klar.
Und was war dann die Strategie?
Weil ich meine, das war halt ein cooler Hack, den musste man öffentlich machen.
Aber im Prinzip war cooler Hack öffentlich machen, was ein neues Element.
Na so neu war das ja nicht, aber es gab eben...
Na wo gab es denn schon Ähnliches?
Na ja, wir haben ja schon von Anfang an eigentlich die Datenschleuder rausgegeben, unser wissenschaftliches Fachblatt für Datenreisende, und da standen alle möglichen Hacks drin. Das war von Anfang an immer alles dokumentiert, was irgendwie witzig war, damit die anderen Leute auch was davon haben.
Ja gut, aber witzig und 135.000 Mark von der Bank abziehen, ist natürlich schon ein ganz anderer Level von Humor.
Na ja, der Humor in der Datenschleuder war der gleiche. Er war nur anders formuliert. Er war immer in der Negation formuliert. Du sollst nicht Draht R1 an Stelle M2 anschließen, sonst würde es wie ein Modem funktionieren. Keinesfalls darfst du diese Lötstelle dann.
Und wir sind sogar so weit gegangen, dass wir wirklich sehr detailliert gesagt haben, was man alles nicht tun darf, also bis hin zu Schaltplänen, was man auf gar keinen Fall zusammenlöten darf. Denn es könnte unter Umständen automatisch den Hörer abnehmen und könnte automatisch mit Pfeiftönen antworten.
Klar, und jetzt war es aber nicht so, ihr dürft nicht den Buffer-Overflow ausnutzen, weil ihr dann ja eine Kennung kommen könntet, mit der ihr euch dann einloggt, und dann dürft ihr nicht einen Roboter anschließen, der dann die ganze Zeit Raute drückt. Sondern ihr habt es ja getan.
Genau, man muss manche Sachen auch einfach mal ausprobieren.
Ja, das stimmt. Was ist dann passiert?
Na ja, und dann brach natürlich der gesamte Medienrummel über uns herein.
Ja, aber wie war denn die Strategie? Ich meine, hat sich jemand erzählt, dann hat sich es rumgesprochen, oder gab es schon richtig Medienattacken mit Pressrelease und Tralala?
Nein, wir waren ja lange nicht so professionell. Also das war... Wir haben bei Steffen in der Bude gesessen und haben irgendwie keine Ahnung. Und haben da ein paar Vire getrunken und haben uns darüber lustig gemacht und sind dann pennen gegangen. Und am nächsten Morgen waren es halt 135.000.
Ja gut, aber danach, wem habt ihr es dann gesagt?
Oh, das habe ich leider vergessen.
Ich habe das immer so wahrgenommen, dass es dann schon so eine mehr oder weniger kontrollierte Pressemeldung gab.
Ja, gab es. Aber ich erinnere nicht mehr die genauen Details und Umstände.
Okay, ich bin jetzt auch mit schwammigen Ausführungen zufrieden.
Also es gab schon eine Information nach draußen. Das musste man ja schon deswegen tun, um sich eben selber zu schützen, damit man eben auch sagen kann, nein, nein, wir wollen es gar nicht haben, das Geld, nein, nein, nein. Denn sonst, ich sage jetzt mal, wenn es darum gegangen wäre, das Geld einzustecken, dann wäre das ja eindeutig kriminell gewesen. Und das ging es ja nicht. Es ging um den Hack und um den Witz und um den Spaß einfach.
Na gut, jetzt wissen wir ja, wie gut Deutschland ist im Spaßverstehen, die nicht so ausgeprägte Eigenschaft der deutschen Kultur. Insofern finde ich es erstaunlich, dass das dann sozusagen auch gelungen ist, dass es eben so wahrgenommen wurde. Was denkst du, woran das lag?
Na ja, es ist leidlich gelungen. Leidlich? Ja, also das Medienecho war zuerst sehr gespalten. Also es war wirklich so, es reichte von alle Einsperren bis Hut ab.
Ja, mit einer Verlagerung. Also war das dann so 50-50?
Ich würde sagen, es war so 50-50. Es war ziemlich auf der Kippe, aber irgendwie eben auch durch die lustigen Gestalten. Also ich meine jetzt, wenn Vau im Fernsehen irgendwas gesagt hatte, dann mussten die Leute erstmal lachen, dann weinen, dann einen Augenblick nachdenken. Da haben die Leute einfach verstanden, das ist irgendwie nicht der Typ kriminell. Das sind irgendwie nicht die typischen Kriminellen. Das haben die Leute dann doch verstanden, glaube ich.
Das heißt, es kam viel über die Persönlichkeit drüber. Was war denn jetzt sozusagen, in meiner Wahrnehmung ist jetzt dieser BTX schon ein bisschen ein Medienurknall gewesen, Datenschleuder hin, Datenschleuder her. Das ist schon so ein Ereignis, an dem eigentlich eine Menge Leute dieses Image des aufklärenden Clubs auch festgemacht haben und auch teilweise auch immer noch festmachen.
Ja, wobei mir eben dieses Aufklärungswort nicht so richtig funktioniert. Das gefällt mir nicht so gut, weil es eigentlich, es war jetzt nicht so, wir sind jetzt da, um die Welt zu retten und euch alle aufzuklären, sondern es hatte eben auch...
Nicht?
Es hatte auch diese Spaß, es hatte im Wesentlichen diese, diese Freiheitsdrang und Ausprobiertrang und sich keine Grenzen setzen lassen wollen Komponente. Und das ist dann irgendwann halt ein bisschen umgeschlagen, die Aufklärungskomponente, weil man eben mit einem, wie der Andreas schon gesagt hat, mit einer Kenntnis im Grunde genommen auch dann irgendwann eine gewisse Verantwortung hat, wenn man so was halt kann, da muss man dann irgendwie am Ende auch verantwortlich umgehen. Das war aber erst der zweite Schritt.
Also war sozusagen erstmal auch ein eigener Lernprozess an der Stelle. In der Folge, ich meine, es gab ja dann weitere solche Ereignisse, die glaube ich auch relativ wackelig waren. Du hast ja schon angesprochen, oder hast du es angesprochen? Ich weiß nicht, aber es lief darauf hinaus, diese NASA Hackgeschichte war dann glaube ich so ein bisschen das nächste, was so in den Blättern geklingelt hat. Da saß er ja noch ein bisschen mehr an der Front, glaube ich. War das dann schon irgendwie anders? Also, ich meine, es hat sich ja dann so eine merkwürdige, bedrohliche Phase auch entwickelt, die auch so für den Club, also bedrohlich vor allem nach innen war, was so das gegenseitige Vertrauen betrifft, einfach ausgelöst durch eine Öffentlichkeit, die zwar auf der einen Seite so mit diesem Robin Hood-Appeal auf den Club blickte und so, ah, hier die Datenretter aus dem Wald, die dann irgendwie so das Geld von den Reichen nehmen unter ihren Armen verteilen. Und ja, das war so das eine romantische Bild, aber dann auf der anderen Seite auch so die Schafmacher, die gesagt haben, oh, die Jungs, die haben ja Gehirne und sie benutzen sie auch, wie gefährlich, da muss man am besten gleich mal drauf schießen, weil, weißt du ja, auf was sie morgen noch so kommen, das war immer so das, was ich auch so aus der Medienberichterstattung so herausgelesen habe. Ich war ja damals noch überhaupt nicht in den Clubreihen aktiv. Und dieser Naserhack spielt dann aber schon auch eine besondere Rolle. Was ist denn da überhaupt vorgefallen?
Also im Grunde genommen war das gar nicht weiter. Also den Naserhack gibt es eigentlich nur aufgrund der Öffentlichkeit. Also wir waren ja überall unterwegs. Ich meine jetzt das europäische Kernforschungszentrum CERN. Da standen Hunderte von Wachsen rum. Und das haben wir jahrelang die Hackerfahrschule genannt, weil die halt total einfach aufzumachen waren. Und da standen die auch, sei es mal Betriebssystemversionen, die man mit wenig Aufwand unter Kontrolle bringen konnte. Und diese Forschungsinstitutionen, hatte ich ja schon erwähnt, die waren halt vernetzt. Na ja, und irgendwann ist man halt auf den NASA-Rechner gelandet. Und das war auch ganz lustig. Die hatten auch eine ganze Menge davon rumstehen. Und wir haben uns halt wirklich auch, ich kann natürlich nur für mich sprechen, ich habe mich köstlich amüsiert, wenn ich gelesen habe, die Berichte, wie sie irgendwelche Raketenexperimente gemacht haben, wo das Ding ist umgekippt und hat einen Hangar irgendwie in die Luft gejagt. Das waren so Sachen, die fanden wir ehrlich, oder ich jedenfalls habe das so wahrgenommen, auch als Spaß. Wir haben uns halt köstlich beölt über die schiefgegangenen Experimente von der NASA. Und haben auf diesen Kisten halt das übliche gemacht. Chat-System installiert, weitergefahren. Also ja, das war im Grunde genommen ein NASA-Hack. Und das Einzige, wir hatten halt ab und zu bei den Sessions damals auch mal Logging mit laufen, nicht? Und eins von diesen Logs ist dann irgendwann im Fernsehen aufgetaucht.
Und wie hat es den Weg dahin gefunden?
Ich glaube, das ist da schon relativ gezielt gelandet. Also ja, naja, also, hm. Also interessierten sich natürlich dann irgendwie auch mehr und mehr Journalisten für das, was wir treiben. Naja, und dieses eine Beispiel hat man halt mal hergenommen.
Also es ist irgendwie aus der Community entwichen, kann man das so formulieren. Okay. Und dann wurde da irgendwas Großes draus, weil irgendwie die Leute draufgeschaut haben und so. Oh Gott, NASA, Computer, Einbruch, große Story. Und für euch war das irgendwie ein Host wie jeder andere.
Ja, es war halt witzig, dass es ausgerechnet die NASA war oder auch was weiß ich, wenn du halt, das war ja, das war ja halt so, Hackvalue hatte halt NASA, Pentagon, was weiß ich, also so, dass man sagt, ich war schon, ich war schon im Pentagon.
Wart ihr da auch?
Da sieht man halt wieder die Datenreisenden. Das waren halt wirklich Backpacker, die als Touristen rumfuhren und gesagt haben, hallo, ich war übrigens auch schon da und schon da und schon da. So wie andere Backpacker sich immer fotografieren lassen vor irgendwelchen Flughäfen.
Die Aufkleber auf den Koffern oder diese kleinen Metallwappen, die man sich auf einen Spazierstock drauf nagelt.
Supercool war auch die Tsukuba-Universität. Da haben wir uns dann alle japanische Namen gegeben, damit wir nicht auffallen.
Und habt ihr euch dafür noch ein Programm geschrieben, was aus euren Vornamen dann entsprechend japanisch klingende Namen machte?
Nö, die haben wir uns einfach selbst ausgedacht.
Weißt du noch?
Meinen? Nishio.
Aha. Und gibt es den auch so? Was? Ist das ein realer, verbreiteter japanischer Name?
Da bin ich leider unsicher. Ich spreche leider kein Japanisch.
Du dachtest dir einfach, das klingt japanisch genug.
Das klingt japanisch genug. Und dann, ja, damit sind wir dann darum geeiert. Und da haben wir auch ein Chat-System installiert, natürlich.
Ich frage natürlich jetzt deshalb vor allem so interessiert, weil es ist natürlich vor allem diese Schnittstelle zwischen dieser inneren, spaßhabenden Szene, nicht wahr, die einfach mit ihrer Neugier sich der Technologie stets immer wieder aufs Neue nähert, mit und ohne typisches Nutzerverhalten. Und dann aber eben ab einem bestimmten Punkt, wo einfach ein öffentliches Interesse einerseits entweder erwächst von sich aus oder ausgelöst wird durch Partialverrat, oder dass man eben auch selber nach außen geht und sagt, hier hör mal, wir haben da was rausbekommen, das solltet ihr euch irgendwie mal anschauen. Das ist ja schon eine sehr prägende Eigenschaft des Clubs, dass er das jetzt so über die Jahre auch, ich will nicht sagen perfektioniert hat, aber zumindest eine gewisse Erfahrung gesammelt hat in der Art und Weise, wie man eben mit der Öffentlichkeit umgeht, sodass die Öffentlichkeit einen dann auch wirklich zur Kenntnis nimmt. Diese ganzen Vorfälle haben natürlich dann auch so eine Reputation gesorgt, die teilweise auch ein bisschen albern ist. Wenn ich irgendwo auftauche und dann so im Namen des Hackens unterwegs bin, dann gibt es immer noch so Leute, die sagen so, oh Hacker, und so muss ich jetzt meinen Computer wegpacken und so. Ja, ich gehe hier immer nicht ins W-Laden, wie auch so die Gäste auf dem Kongress ja auch immer. Na gut, da vielleicht auch zurecht ein bisschen Angst haben um ihre Maschinen.
Da jedenfalls wurden dann irgendwann auch die Amis relativ unentspannt. Da ist ja dann auch dieses politische Clifford-Stallbuch erschienen. Und die haben ja dann da schon versucht, eben alles mitzuhören und alles zurückzuverfolgen und was weiß ich nicht alles. Und da haben sich dann eben zwei incompatible Attitüden getroffen, würde ich sagen.
American Government und German Hackers.
Na ja, und da war dann eben von unserer Seite nach wie vor immer noch dieses Spaßmoment und von der anderen Seite schon oh, keine Ahnung, Staatsbedrohung und Cyberkrieg und was weiß ich nicht alles, was sie sich da schon ausgemalt hatten.
Ja, weil man dann schnell auch auf der Terror-Ecke. Das würde ja dann auch zu ausreichend paranoia.
Gut, aber die Wechselwirkungen sind halt sehr spannend zu gucken. Was schlägt von außen dann auf die Szene? Wie verändert sich die Szene innen durch diesen Druck, der außen aufgebaut wird? Und was sind auch so Fluchtmomente? Was sind Ausdrucksmomente? Wie versucht man mit diesen engsten Sorgen, mit der Paranoia umzugehen, mit dem Misstrauen als interner Prozess im Menschen und dann intersubjektiv als Gruppe? Und da hat ja auch Medienarbeit sicherlich immer wieder gezeigt, wie man da so einen Weg rausfinden kann, wie man halt versuchen kann, die eigene Sicht darzustellen. Und ich denke, das zeigt der Club ganz gut, wie sich in 30 Jahren auch die Technologie verändert hat, mit der man diese Dinge zum Ausdruck bringen kann. Während das ja anfangs primär das gesprochene Wort irgendwo in den staatlichen Medien war, ist es zum Beispiel auch mit Chaosradio Express inzwischen so, dass wir einfach auch ein Forum haben, über das wir uns an die Welt wenden können und sagen können, das ist das, wie wir die Welt sehen. Das ist ja auch nur unsere kleine Sicht der Dinge und denkt halt drüber nach und kommentiert das. Aber dass das auch ja damit zusammenhing, wie sich die Produktionsmittelverfügbarkeit verändert hat, das ist inzwischen einfach sehr billig, ist ein Tonstudio so zu bauen, dass man es im ICE mit sich herumfahren kann, wie du das tust. Und das ist denke ich auch so eine Demokratisierungswirkung von Technologie, dass es also Einzelnen möglich wird, sich auszudrücken. Und das ist ja immer auch was, was wir in der Kunst sehen. Zum Beispiel eben mit den Rap-Rap-Maschinen, dass also deine Fertigungstechnologie entsteht für in dem Fall physische Dinge, bei dir eben für Materialgüter wie ein Podcast oder ein Video, mit dem man sich eben äußern kann, mit dem man versuchen kann, Kommunikation durchzuführen. Letztlich ist das ja nichts anderes.
Aber bleiben wir nochmal weiter beim Club ganz konkret. Du bist ja jetzt eine andere Generation noch, ein oder zwei, je nachdem, wie man das so rechnen will, hinter uns. Du hast ja auch den Club am Anfang im Wesentlichen über diese Medien wahrgenommen, nehme ich an. Was war denn dein Eindruck? Oder was ist vorgefallen, dass du da überhaupt aufmerksam geworden bist? Weißt du das noch?
Ja, und das sind aber zwei desjungte Dinge. Das eine war die Art und Weise, wie die Kommunikation nach außen stattfindet und wie ein bisschen die Kommunikation im Inneren stattfindet, soweit es mir möglich war, das zu sehen. Hauptsächlich vermittelt durch Mailboxen.
Was ist denn die Kommunikation im Inneren?
D-Org CCC zum Beispiel.
Ach so, aber du musstest es ja auch erst mal hinfinden. Wie bist du denn überhaupt da drauf gestoßen und bist da nicht im Club aufgewachsen?
Nö, aber das weiß ich gar nicht mehr, wie ich da drüber stieße. Ich glaube, ich habe einfach alle deutschen Usenet-Gruppen in der Org-Kategorie angeguckt und es waren ja nur drei. Und eine davon war D-Org CCC.
Wir reden jetzt von Anfang der 90er Jahre?
Und da gab es halt genau drei in dieser Hierarchie und das eine war der Chaos Computer Club.
Was? Es gab nur drei D.E.-Gruppen?
Nein, DE. Org.
Ach, D.Org-Gruppen. Ja, das stimmt. Ach so, was waren nochmal die anderen beiden? Gab es da schon, weiß nicht, Viethoek oder was?
Ne, das war, glaube ich, wie hießen denn diese Leute in München um Gabriele? CL-Net?
Kann sein. Ja, du hast recht. Genau, stimmt. Ach, D.Org CCC. Oh man, Schänderung.
Das war interessant, weil diese Innenwahrnehmung, oder wie weit auch immer es Innen war, das waren hochintelligente Leute, die sich anfänglich sehr diszipliniert, aber auch sehr kritisch miteinander auseinandergesetzt haben, was ja auch später was war, was ich dann noch stärker im Club erlebt habe. Jedweil der 1. Sitzung war eine Katastrophe gegen die Art und Weise, wie Plenum geführt wurde, bis FIFA irgendwann auftauchte. Aber das war in D.Org CCC genau das Gleiche, dass da einfach der Laute war, der pöbelte, und alle anderen haben sich unglaublich diszipliniert über Inhalte ausgetauscht, zum Teil auch scharf, aber nicht auf einer persönlichen Ebene. Es war ein persönlicher Respekt da. Und es ging um Sachthemen, die durchgeführt wurden, wo man versucht hat, mit welchen Mitteln können wir dieses Sachthema erreichen, und wie kann man das kommunizieren, wie kann man das umsetzen, wie setzt man Prioritäten. Es ist wichtiger, das zuerst zu kommunizieren, es ist wichtiger, das erst zu machen. Und das habe ich dann halt auch im realen Leben kennengelernt, als ich die Leute dann tatsächlich mal vor Ort besucht habe.
Aber ich wollte jetzt aber bewusst sozusagen nicht auf diese interne Kommunikation hinaus, weil ich denke, wenn man den Club kulturell als solchen kennengelernt hat, dann ist das eh nochmal eine andere Geschichte. Aber wie war sozusagen deine Wahrnehmung über diese Medien, die jetzt sozusagen nicht der Club selbst war, oder Club-gestaltete Medien waren?
Das war primär 23 und 42, das war die Paranoia und die lösungsorientierte ganzheitliche Sicht. Und das waren Andy und Vau. Andy war immer so das Poster-Child für Hacker sind die Bösen, selber Kriminellen. Und man muss ja auf der anderen Seite als Hacker Angst haben vor dem totalitären Staat, der alle überwacht. Und deswegen ist es so ein Akt der Rebellion, irgendwie Cyber-Terrorist zu sein. Sonst war das der Eindruck damals, den ich gewann. Und auf der anderen Seite war Vau, der versucht hat, das immer mit einem sehr starken, sozial-kritischen Ansatz zu machen und zu sagen, gut, wir schaffen hier Lösungen für die Transformation in die Informationsgesellschaft. Ich hab damals die Tofflers gelesen, also Future Shock, wo es darum geht. Es gibt so drei Zukunftswellen. Die erste ist, dass sich der Mensch sozusagen vom Jäger und Sammler in der Agrargesellschaft zum Vorartfest-Verankerten verwandelt, wo auch dann der Ortsbegriff plötzlich eine ganz andere Rolle spielt, wo irgendwie Gemeinschaften erwachsen, die vorher eine ganz andere Rolle hatten bei nomadischen Völkern. Die zweite Welle ist dann die Industrialisierung, dass also der Mensch herausgelöst wird aus seinem mit der Natur verbundenen Kontext und plötzlich irgendwie stupide Fertigungsschritte am Fließband in Norditalien, in England, wo auch immer macht. Und was das für Auswirkungen auf die Umwelt hat, was das für Auswirkungen auf den Menschen, auf die Seele, auf den eigenen Umgang, auf die Kommunikation untereinander bedeutet. Und der dritte Schock eben diese Informationsgesellschaft, dass plötzlich Wissen nicht mehr ein kostbares Gut ist, das nur über physische Transportmedien vermittelt wird, das Zeit in Anspruch nimmt, sondern dass es möglich sein wird in der Zukunft, statt eine Reise zu unternehmen, ein Bild am Schreibtisch zu erfassen. Das, was dann Bill Gates als kommerzielle Vision, als Information at your fingertips verkauft hat, war ja genau diese Transformation zur Informationsgesellschaft. Wissen ist dann plötzlich kostenlos verfügbar. Und es gibt eben auch nicht mehr dieses klassische Sender-Empfängermodell. Jemand, ein Professor schreibt ein Physikbuch, sondern der Physikstudent sagt, da hat er sich aber vertan. Und ich stelle es mal in die Wikipedia. Und diese Vision war ja damals auch schon längst angelegt. Das Buch ist aus den späten 70ern. Und natürlich, was mich im Club immer dann wieder die Innensicht, oder das war so ein bisschen das verbindende Element zwischen dem von außen und um nach innen zu kommen, auch die Themen kennenzulernen, worüber wird da gesprochen, war natürlich die Literatur. War immer das, was wird gelesen. Es waren ja sehr belesene Menschen, die ich da getroffen habe. Und eins der verbindenden Werke war sicherlich eben auch der Schockwellenreiter, der von John Brunner als Reaktion auf diesen Future-Schock, auf diese Zukunftsangst, diesen überrumpelnden Effekt der Zukunft, diese Welle, die da auftritt. Letztlich als Reaktion gibt es halt jemand, der surft mit dieser Welle. Und das war immer ein schönes Bild für mich für das, was Hacker ausmachen. Klar gibt es da jetzt eine Schockwelle, die alle erschütternd wird und die einmal um den Planeten geht. Aber man kann ja auch oben mitsurfen und sich aus guter Position angucken, was es überrollt und wie es dann hinten aussieht. Und ja, das war eben dieses Gefühl des Surfers, des Datenreisenden, der auf der Schockwelle reitet und sich die Veränderung ansieht und im Zweifel vielleicht auch mitgestalten kann, indem man den Leuten vor sich irgendwas zuruft.
Schöne Vorlage. Ich meine, wenn man sich jetzt gerade die Diskussion über die Auswirkungen der Informationsgesellschaft in diesem Jahr anschaut, ja, ich will jetzt hier nicht die Google Street View...
Das stand vor 20 Jahren alles schon in der Datenschläge.
Aber wenn man sich das jetzt anschaut, hat man genau das Gefühl, dass diese Schockwelle quasi da auch einige kräftig erwischt. Genau, die kommt irgendwie gerade an. Beziehungsweise je nachdem, auf welcher Frequenz man so resoniert, hat es andere Leute vielleicht schon so ein bisschen eher erwischt. So ein paar scheinen jetzt erst davon betroffen zu sein, und dann scheint es auch besonders hart zu sein.
Ich denke, das ist bei denen, um bei dem Bild zu bleiben, bei denjenigen, die freiwillig wussten, dass es passieren wird, und sich auf den Weg gemacht haben, ins EP-Zentrum zu gehen, um den großen Knall live mitzuerleben. Die werden natürlich von den kleinen Ausläufern nicht mehr so erfassen, sagen, na ja nun. Aber diejenigen, die am Rand der Wüste standen und plötzlich die Spitze der Schockwelle sehen, sind natürlich erschrocken und fragen sich, wo soll das hin und rennen, kopflos über die Wiese?
Der Hacker steht sozusagen im Auge des Tornados. Wundert sich, warum die anderen alle so herumwirbeln. Ja, da ist was dran. Was natürlich auch so ein bisschen was über das Unverständnis der Eingeweihten sagt, ja, warum die anderen jetzt sich davon überhaupt so tangiert fühlen. Da ist echt was dran.
Und das war halt auch schon früh angelegt. Also selbst als ich in den Club kam, gab es immer dieses die anderen und wir. Also das hat sich dann ja auch wieder in der Musik irgendwie dargelegt. Es gab ja viele irgendwie das, was heute vermutlich, weiß nicht, Metal-Fans oder Piratenpartei Zielgruppe eher wäre. Gab es ja auch im Club. Leute, die dann Sepultura hörten, We Who Are Not As Others, bevor sie angefangen haben, Mails zu schreiben oder Mails zu lesen jeden Morgen. Ich habe da ja viel auch den tatsächlichen Backpacker gespielt und mich halt bei Leuten einquartiert, was immer auch großartig war, diese Gastfreundschaft zu sehen. Dass man halt als Hacker jederzeit zu jedem anderen kommen konnte und dort gastfreundlich empfangen wurde. Man als Bücheregal gehen durfte, irgendwo eine Ecke für einen Schlafsack hatte. Meistens auf dem Fußboden zwischen unglaublich viel Technik. Räum doch mal die Lötstation weg und nimm die Kabeltrommel da raus, dann kannst du da dich irgendwo zusammenrollen. Letztlich war das immer auch so ein verbindendes Element. Literatur, Musik, was sind diese gemeinsamen Dinge? Diese Gemeinsamkeit hat aber auch so einen Innen- und Außen dargestellt und so eine Gruppenzugehörigkeit erzeugt. Und aber eben auch das Außen, dass man gesagt hat, naja, der ist halt Politiker, der kann es ja nicht wissen. Auch mit so einem mitleidigen Lächeln manchmal. Was aber denke ich auch die Realität halt sicherlich widerspiegelt. Also es war ja schon ein funktionales Element, diese Gruppenbildung, dass man dann gesagt hat, das ist jemand von der Journal, jeder kann keine Ahnung haben. Und das hat mich immer fasziniert, wie sehr dann zum Beispiel Vau sich Zeit genommen hat, mit einer Eselsgeduld es zu erklären, oder auch Andi, der 74 Interviews gegeben hat am Tag, und ich neben ihm saß, weil ich bei ihm war, und er 74 Interviews am Telefon gegeben hat, manchmal auf zwei Telefonen zeitgleich, und erklärt hat, was ist der I-love-you-Virus und warum muss man keine Angst haben, und Angst ist ein schlechter Ratgeber. Nein, und mit einer Eselsgeduld versucht hat, den Menschen zu erklären, was ist es, weil ja auch immer der Club so ein Anlaufpunkt war, für die Menschen eben außerhalb. Die sehen, da kommt die Schockwelle auf mich zu, ich versteh's nicht, dann rufen wir halt die an, die da hinten stehen, die haben's offensichtlich überlebt.
Aber wenn man jetzt aus dieser ganzen Situation mal so ein Videogame macht, so und der Hacker da im Auge des Sturms, ja, hat so die ganzen Kühe und Politiker, die um den herum drehen, ja, und dann so mit dem digitalen Lasso in der Hand versucht er jetzt da, die wieder auf den Boden der Tatsachen zurückzuziehen, ja. Also, welche Strategie müsste man denn da jetzt an den Tag legen, um den Highscore zu erzielen?
Das ist halt die Frage, ob man fundamental daran glaubt, dass sich das ändern lässt. Das ist denke ich immer eine individuelle Entscheidung, ob man sich durch Abschottung oder durch Öffnen, durch Aufklärung mit Dingen auseinandersetzt. Natürlich ist es schrecklich, wenn man das erste Mal die Augen aufmacht und sieht, wie tragisch das alles ist, bis man sich irgendwann daran gewöhnt, vielleicht auch ein bisschen zynisch oder paranoid wird, und dann damit umgehen kann. Und eins der Bücher von John Brunner, das auch Standard war, heißt Schafe blicken auf. Und es gibt ein berühmtes Zitat, um ein gutes Mitglied einer Schafherde zu sein, muss man zunächst mal ein Schaf sein. Und das war halt im Club eher so, dass es immer die Wölfe waren, die Alphatiere. Und ich denke, das ist ein Charakteristikum, dass man auch eben losgeht und sagt, ich will was verändern, und jetzt tue ich es verdammt nochmal. Mir doch egal, ob da eine Wand ist.
Das hat natürlich auch Grenzen. Ich meine, wir paar komische Verrückte können ja nicht die Welt retten. Nicht? Da müssen schon ein paar mehr mithelfen.
Ja gut, aber ihr merkt schon, worauf ich hinausfälle. Also dieses Spannungsfeld Öffentlichkeit hier und so aufgeklärte Alternativkulturminderheit auf der anderen Seite, die man alles besser weiß. Und man möchte halt die Dinge jetzt irgendwie bringen. Ihr wart ja nun beide auf verschiedene Arten und Weisen, auch mit der Außenwelt sozusagen in Feindkontakt. Ich selbst hab da jetzt gar nicht so viel Erfahrung mit, hab jetzt nicht so viel mit Ministerien gesprochen. Ich hab jetzt auch nicht für den Club in irgendwelchen Gremien gesessen. Ihr habt das ja beide schon irgendwie mit durchgemacht. Was sind denn so eure Erfahrungen, wenn man dann sozusagen dann auch mal real da in Berührung kommt? Welche Art von Missverständnissen, Unverständnissen gibt es? Was sind so die Elemente, die auch wirklich klärend gewirkt haben? Wie kann man politischen Einfluss dann auch wirklich in die Wege leiten? Oder ist das alles vollkommen...
Ich denke, was neu ist, das hat es nämlich in der Anfangszeit nicht gegeben, dass tatsächlich Leute zu uns kommen und uns fragen, weil sie eben festgestellt haben, dass da so eine gewisse Kompetenz zusammengekommen ist und dass die Leute eben tatsächlich, jetzt bevor sie anfangen auf irgendwas rumzuprügeln oder sich eine Meinung zu bilden, tatsächlich zu uns kommen und fragen. Und das ist eigentlich relativ neu. Und wenn uns jemand gefragt hat, haben wir schon immer eine Antwort gegeben. Das gehört auch zu unserer Kultur. Es gibt keine Geheimnisse in dem Sinne, sondern Geheimnis ist... Also das Gegenteil ist eigentlich der Fall. Deswegen heißt ja unser Blatt auch die Datenschleuder. Es geht eben darum, die Daten...
Ja klar, aber nicht jeder, der uns jetzt zuhört, ist ja Chaos Computer Club und da geht nicht automatisch die Tür im Wohnzimmer auf und es kommt jemand rein und fragt. Aber trotzdem hat ja jeder Einzelne, der so ein bisschen diesen aufgeklärten Blick hat und vielleicht dann so auch unsere Ansichtswelt, der Welt so teilt, den Wunsch in seinem unmittelbaren Umfeld, wie weit das auch immer greifen mag, Einfluss zu nehmen. Die Piratenpartei ist auch so ein Projekt, die jetzt sich da quasi gefunden hat, um das in Angriff zu nehmen und fährt natürlich da auch gerade durch die entsprechend schweren Wasser, um da Erfolge zu landen. Aber auch im Einzelnen wird man ja immer wieder ähnliche Erfahrungen machen. Welche Erfahrungen habt ihr denn gemacht? Du warst doch jetzt hier zum Beispiel in diesem, wie hieß das noch gleich, diese IT?
Du meinst den Datenschutzbeirat?
Genau, diesen Datenschutzbeirat, was für ein Wort.
Na ja, gut, das braucht halt solche Wörter. Das ist halt ein Gremium, was die Deutsche Telekom eingeführt hat nach ihren Skandalen, um da mal einen konstruktiven Ansatz zu wählen. Und hat da halt verschiedene Leute eingeladen, Wissenschaftler, Politiker und unter anderem eben auch mich.
Und dann?
Na ja, und dann versucht man sozusagen erst mal dort, arbeitet man das erst mal auf, was der Stand ist, und versucht dann eben Empfehlungen zu geben, wie man es machen kann, um sozusagen, ja, um den Laden, sage ich jetzt mal, datenschutzmäßig umzugestalten. Also mehr darauf zu achten, dass man auf die Persönlichkeitsrechte von Mitarbeitern und Kunden und sowas, dass man die besser schützen kann.
Ja, aber was hast du denn so für Erfahrungen gemacht? Was für Leute laufen denn da auf?
Na ja, da laufen...
Das sind alles so die Experten und die haben irgendwie voll die Schäckung und das sind so die Leute der zweiten Reihe, von denen man immer gehofft hat, dass es sie gibt und jetzt sind sie da und da ist auch gleich alles konstruktiv, oder?
Na, das ist eine Mischung. Das ist eine ziemlich inhomogene Mischung. Also zum einen sitzen da halt Bundestagsabgeordnete von den großen Fraktionen, weil das ist ja letztlich der Gesellschafter von der Telekom. Der ist immer mit dabei. Und dann sind da eben, sag ich jetzt mal, Leute aus dem, wie soll ich sagen, universitären Bereich, also so herausragende Persönlichkeiten. Der Hansjörg Geiger zum Beispiel sitzt da mit drin und der Schäfer, die sich eben auch mit solchen Sachen schon beschäftigt haben.
Kannst du mal sagen, was deren Rolle ist?
Der eine ist... Geiger war, glaube ich, BND-Präsident.
Er war Präsident des Inlandsgeheimdienstes Deutschlands, des Auslandsgeheimdienstes und war Staatssekretär im Staatsministerium.
Staatssekretär, genau.
Den haben wir auch in der CAE 159 schon dran. Und der Schäfer?
Der ist ehemaliger Bundesrichter, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht. Leute mit juristischer Kompetenz, Leute mit organisatorischer Kompetenz, da würde ich mal den Herrn Geiger dazu rechnen. Und dann eben typischerweise Fachpolitiker, wobei ich da bei einigen mit Fachpolitiker Schwierigkeiten habe. Also beispielsweise der Herr Bosbach sitzt da auch.
Der ist ja auch mal für sehr kluge Vorschläge in der Öffentlichkeit bekannt.
Das ist was, was sich in all den Veranstaltungen, auf denen ich war, in all den Gremien immer durchgezogen hat, dass es eine klare Trennung gibt zwischen denjenigen, die das freiwillig machen, also den zum Beispiel in Nichtregierungsorganisationen, in den Menschenrechtsgruppen, die immer ein sehr klares Themengebiet haben, sehr klaren Fokus, in dem sie unglaublich gut vernetzen, in dem sie sich sehr gut auskennen. Und dann gibt es darüber eine Ebene, sozusagen in die Breite gehend, wo sie ihre Anknüpfungspunkte haben und wo sie aber immer die richtigen Leute kennen. Das war ja bei uns einfach Vau, der zu jeder Gruppe, die es irgendwo gab, die ein soziales Anliegen hatte, einen Kontakt hinhatte, weil sie gesagt haben, du kannst uns die Computer erklären. Und der gesagt hat, gut, dann erklärt ihr mir den Menschenrechtsdialog oder was auch immer es war. Und die sind sehr engagiert in der Regel, weil sie das nicht aus materiellem Interesse machen. Und weil sie immer noch ein Akteur sind, der halt versuchen muss, auch natürlich so eine klientelistische Politik zu verfolgen, aber die ein klares Ziel haben. Dann gibt es auf jeden Fall diejenigen in den Ministerien, die oft ebenso große Sachkenntnis haben, aber natürlich ganz anders an das Thema herangehen müssen, auch weil sie natürlich so einem Ausgleich verpflichtet sind. Und dann gibt es die Politiker, bei denen es offensichtlich in der Regel nur darum geht, möglichst viele Stimmen zu bekommen, Karriere zu machen und die Themen nicht aufgreifen, weil sie sie interessieren, weil sie Stimmen bringen. Und wenn ich zum Beispiel bei Menschenrechtsgruppen war, wenn ich bei Umweltschutzorganisationen war, wenn ich bei Friedensforschern war, dann ging es da immer darum, welche Werkzeuge könnt ihr bereitstellen, welche Veränderungen wird stattfinden, welche Konsequenzen hat es für unsere Arbeit. In den Ministerien war es, was sehen Sie als Problem, das wir möglicherweise regeln müssen, wo besteht Regelungsbedarf und wo glauben Sie, dass eine Re-Regulierung oder Deregulierung stattfinden muss, wo ist also eine staatliche Kontrolle vielleicht auch nicht mehr nötig, wo wird sie nötig sein, was kann man dem Markt überlassen, was nicht.
Ja, ein sehr produktiver Ansatz.
Die meisten davon sind auch tatsächlich Leute, mit denen ich sehr gerne arbeite, wo man merkt, die versuchen im Rahmen ihrer Möglichkeiten, also finanzieller Nöte oder Vorgaben von oben, das Bestmögliche mit den Mitteln zu erreichen. Und das war sehr schön, was mich auch an Europa fasziniert, an westlichen Demokratien. Man kann überall hinfahren, man kann mit allen sprechen, alle hören einem zu und alle helfen einem auch, ihre Sicht zu verstehen, das darzulegen und das Dilemma, in dem sie stecken. Das ist bei politischen Parteien grundsätzlich anders. Da geht es immer nur darum, die eigene Sicht durchzukämpfen und Wählerstimmen zu bekommen. Und wenn es gerade nicht auf Parteilinie passt, dann fällt es hinten runter. Und die Parteilinie kann sich von heute auf morgen ändern. Eines der schlimmsten Momente war der letzte SPD-Parteitag, auf dem ich war, als es um Web-Sperren ging. Und die sind einfach binnen 20 Minuten komplett umgekippt der Fraktionsdisziplin wegen. Und dann habe ich auch beschlossen für mich, ich gehe einfach nie wieder zu politischen Parteien.
Also du meinst den Parteitag vor den letzten Wahlen, sozusagen. Wo das Thema nicht aufgegriffen werden wollte. Und es gab ja danach, glaube ich, noch mal einen Parteitag, und da war das dann wieder alles andersrum.
Genau. Und dann habe ich für mich beschlossen, ich versuche einfach politische Parteien möglichst auszulassen. Ich will lieber mit politischen Parteien in der Regierung sprechen und nicht mit denen im Parlament, denn das ist verschwendete Lebenszeit. Und das ist das Tragische, was sich auch ein bisschen zeigt, wo die Frage ist, wie kann Technik das möglicherweise lösen? Wie kann offene Kommunikation das lösen? Dass dieser Transformationsriemen den Parteien ja eigentlich darstellen. Also der Versuch, gesellschaftlich relevante Themen zu entdecken und in den politischen Entscheidungsprozess zu überführen, sofern das Thema groß genug ist. Dass das nicht funktioniert, das funktioniert unfassbar schlecht. Und das tragische ist, dass es ja immer noch besser ist als überall sonst. Also das ist das beste System, das momentan existiert. Und die Frage ist, wie kann man systemanalytisch dieses System verbessern? Und das geht aber halt auch nur wieder mit all den anderen Gruppen. Und das ist das, was den Club immer auch ausgezeichnet hat. Egal, wer im Club nach außen gesprochen hat, war immer klar, es gibt Themen, zu denen können wir uns äußern. Und es gibt Themen, von denen haben wir keine Ahnung. Das ist sicherlich auch immer so ein Grenzbereich, ein Graubereich, wo man sagt, sollen wir uns zu dem mal äußern und unsere Sicht geben. Aber meistens wird es ja dann auch genau als die eigene Sichtweise dargestellt. Das heißt, es ist schon in der Regel so, dass man trennt zwischen dem objektiven Tatbestand, wie funktioniert die Technik und was ist unsere politische Forderung. Und das ist auch bei sehr vielen anderen sozialen Gruppen so. Und die Trennung fehlt mir manchmal ein bisschen in der Parteipolitik.
Was kann man denn jetzt bewirken? Das ist, glaube ich, immer so eine Frage, die sich viele stellen. Ich meine, jetzt habt ihr gesagt, okay, man kommt in diese Gremien, die sind alle irgendwie offen, aber die erklären einem irgendwie auch die Zwänge. Die öffentliche Diskussion ist ja dann meistens immer sehr von den Besetzen von Maximalforderungen dominiert. Das kennt man ja eigentlich so auch aus unseren Kreisen, nicht wahr? Das und das darf nie und nimmer passieren. Gerade jetzt so mit dieser Datenschutzrunde, denke ich mal, muss man sich da eigentlich auf eine ganz andere Kompromisslinie einlassen oder kann man da irgendwie mit der Maximalforderung in der Ecke bleiben und der wilde CCC sein?
Na ja, da das ja nun im Wesentlichen nicht so öffentlich abgefeiert wird, kann man da natürlich durchaus seine Position behalten. Oder ich denke, man muss nicht, aber man sieht dann auch, man lernt eben wieder was. Also das Besondere daran ist ja, egal was man tut und egal in welcher Runde man unterwegs ist, man lernt immer wieder was. Und man lernt zum Beispiel in so einer Runde, dass bestimmte Dinge, die man sich vorstellen würde in einem kommerziellen Umfeld, einfach schlichtweg, sage ich jetzt mal, sehr unwahrscheinlich umgesetzt werden. Also weil ja eben, wenn du jetzt...
Hast du mal ein Beispiel?
Naja, so eine Aktiengesellschaft, so eine große Aktiengesellschaft, die hat ja vielerlei Gremien, die alle irgendwie auf die Steuerung wirken von diesem riesigen Ding. Und da gibt es halt manche Sachen, also in einem kommerziellen Unternehmen kannst du zum Beispiel nichts bringen, was dazu führt, dass dieses kommerzielle Unternehmen untergeht. Das ist einfach eine Forderung, die kannst du zwar stellen, aber da kannst du dir sicher sein, die wird nicht umgesetzt. Also wenn du jetzt irgendwas vorschlägst, was dazu führt, dass die Kosten, die Einnahmen übersteigen, dann kannst du davon ausgehen, dass das nicht umgesetzt wird. Das ist halt auch so eine Erkenntnis, und welche Punkte jetzt da die speziellen sind.
Jawohl, es sei denn, der Gesetzgeber wirkt darauf hin, unabhängig von dem Unternehmen.
Ja, dann geht das eben unter, das Unternehmen. Ja, okay, also wenn du jetzt eine Gesellschaft dazu führt, das Unternehmen unterzugehen, das passiert ja gelegentlich.
Ja, soll schon mal vorgekommen sein.
Eben, das ist der Gesetzgeber, das ist ja auch die Macht, die er hat, dass er das tun kann, und dann gehen die eben unter. Aber wenn du jetzt in dem Unternehmen selber konstruktiv tätig bist, kannst du ja nicht vorschlagen, ich schlage jetzt vor, dass das Unternehmen untergeht. Ich meine, das ist einfach absurd.
Ja, okay, gut.
Also ich denke, die Betrachtung der Ebenen ist eine sehr wichtige Rolle, auf welcher Ebene man versucht, was zu erreichen und was das geeignete ist und mit wem man das tun kann. Aber du fragtest ja auch so, was kann man tun, was kann man bewegen? Ich denke, was wir als technische Szene bewegen können, ist sicherzustellen, dass es frei ungehinderte Kommunikation geben wird. Denn ich habe zu unfassbar vielen Themen eine Meinung, zu deutlich weniger Themen im Plan und zu noch weniger Themen Zeit, um mich darum zu kümmern. Aber das ist auch gar kein Problem, denn die Welt ist bunt und groß und es gibt ganz viele andere, die das tun. Und das eine, was ich im persönlichen Gespräch versuche, ist einfach mit anderen mich auszutauschen und zu sehen, kann ich irgendwo Interesse erwecken für einen offenen Dialog und hoffen, dass das diejenigen auch tun. Denn wenn alle aufgeschlossenen Menschen versuchen, einen offenen Dialog zu führen, wird es vielleicht auch irgendwann Früchte tragen bei jenen, die sich da momentan zurückziehen und ausschließen, sei es aus mangelnden Faktenwissen, sei es aus Interesse, was ja auch deren freie Entscheidung ist. Aber um das tun zu können, können wir eine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur bereitstellen, die nicht gefiltert, zensiert und eingeschränkt und eingehegt ist, die nicht weggesperrt ist in Kryptoflaschen mit Digital Restrictions Management, also mit der Einschränkung von Inhalten. Und das ist denke ich der Kampf, den wir führen werden, sicherzustellen, dass es eine Kommunikationsinfrastruktur gibt, auf der sich alle gleichberechtigt austauschen können und möglicherweise dann sogar noch soziale Richtlinien schaffen können, wie dieses genutzt werden soll. Aber das zugrundeliegende ist sicherlich eine technische Infrastruktur, die agnostisch gegenüber Inhalten ist, die netzneutral ist, die möglichst verschlüsselt ist und die Anonymität erlaubt. Denn dieses unbestimmte Gefühl der Überwachung führt zu einer Internalisierung von Kontrolle und führt dazu, dass man sich nicht mehr in dem Maße am demokratischen Leben und am Willensbildungsprozess beteiligt, wie es normativ wünschenswert und gefordert und notwendig ist, um den demokratischen Rechtsstaat aufrechtzuerhalten. Und das ist das Einzige, was ich sehe, was ich tun kann, ist Kommunikationsinfrastruktur betreiben, daran zu forschen und sicherzustellen in der politischen Arena, dass die Forderungen nach freier Kommunikation, ungehinderter Kommunikation weiterhin Gehör finden.
Jetzt will ich zum Schluss aber doch nochmal das P-Wort auf den Tisch legen, die Piratenpartei und zwar spezifisch die Piratenpartei in Deutschland, weil man ja schon sagen kann, dass das, wenn ich jetzt, also es ist ja nichts, was der CCC initiiert hat, aber sicherlich hat das Wirken und die Arbeit des Clubs auch viel von dem beeinflusst, was sich heute an politischer Kultur in der Piratenpartei wiederfindet, abgesehen davon, dass wir auch alle viele Leute kennen, die jetzt lange Jahre auch im Club aktiv gewesen sind und jetzt eben auch versuchen, in der Piratenpartei was zu bewegen. Wie seht ihr das Entstehen der Partei und die Chancen und Risiken, die jetzt konkret eben die Möglichkeiten betrifft als Partei, als gewählter Organisationsform? Ich meine, wir sind ja bewusst auch immer ein Verein oder bewusst auch kein Verein gewesen. Ja, sozusagen eine lose Gruppe, die sich eben vor allem auch...
Eine galaktische Vereinigung ohne feste Strukturen.
Genau, eine galaktische Vereinigung ohne feste Strukturen, die aber aus bürokratischen Detailgründen dann eben auch noch einen EV gegründet hat. Aber Partei sein ist ja etwas, was sozusagen im Club so nie en vogue war. Was sind da so eure Berührungspunkte bisher gewesen? Wie bewertet ihr das?
Also ich finde dieses Liquid Feedback System eine total coole Sache. Also ich finde, das müssen sie unbedingt schaffen, das durchzusetzen, dass sie intern das benutzen, weil das so eine Art Real-Life-Experiment ist. Das ist ein Real-Life-Experiment, das man nirgendswo anders als dort machen kann eigentlich. Und ich hoffe, dass sie es schaffen, dass wir eben daraus die Erkenntnisse, ich möchte unbedingt die Erkenntnisse daraus lernen. Wir können jetzt hier nicht Liquid Feedback erklären.
Ja, das habe ich auch schon gemacht. Das Chaosradio Express 158 hat sich da ausführlich zu geäußert.
Wunderbar. Jedenfalls ist das eben auch wieder eine Idee, Technologie als Demokratiewerkzeug zu benutzen. Und die muss unbedingt ausprobiert werden, damit wir alle davon lernen können. Und deswegen finde ich es super cool, dass sie den Beschluss gefasst haben, das zu tun. Leider gibt es da auch ein paar Gegner, die versuchen das zu stoppen oder so aus irgendwelchen Gründen, auf die ich nicht näher eingehen möchte. Ich finde, das muss probiert werden. Und ich finde es ein super spannendes Real-Life-Experiment. Und ich freue mich auf die Ergebnisse, so sie denn jemals zur Verfügung stehen werden.
Aber jetzt ist ja die Piratenpartei nicht das Liquid-Feedback-System. Und vor allem, worauf ich erst mal hinaus wollte, habt ihr ja eure Erfahrung mit Parteien. Gerade bei dem, was wir besprochen haben, war ja gerade alles, was mit Partei zu tun hat, dass es immer da, wo so die Fragezeichen in die Runde gestreut werden.
Na ja, im Moment sind die halt noch sehr frisch.
Ja gut, aber wie seht ihr da die Chancen?
Äh, Gott, das, also da, also da...
Oder die Risiken.
Ich hab meine Glaskugel gerade nicht dabei, aber ich meine jetzt...
Nicht, scheiße.
Äh, das, es gibt ja so...
Ich hab's auch gesagt, ich nehm sie mit.
Es gibt ja so Bewegungen, die halt so aus der Bevölkerung kommen. Und da war ja eben so, die Grünen waren ja auch mal eine relativ frische Bewegung. Und davon ist ja auch nicht mehr so wahnsinnig viel übrig geblieben. Und insofern will ich jetzt mal für die Zukunft, für die mittlere und fernere Zukunft, da keine Prognose abgeben. Im Moment ist das eine sehr agile Bewegung. Und es macht mir eben Spaß, dabei zuzugucken. Ob sie so agil bleiben wird, wenn sie dann erstmal gewählt ist und irgendwo im Bundestag sitzt und sich dann diesen... auch durch diese Betriebsübung in den jeweiligen Gremien geschliffen wird und dann eben auch zu einem langweiligen, grauen Stück Partei geschliffen wird, was dann so als graues Törtchen irgendwo in irgendwelchen bunten Grafiken auf irgendwelchen Fernsehern auftaucht.
Derzeit sind es ja orange.
Orange, ja, die Farbe spielt dabei keine große Rolle. Also, ich meine jedenfalls... Das wage ich nicht, woherzusehen. Vielleicht ist es auch ein Grundprinzip, dass jede Partei, die erfolgreich ist, irgendwann verbraucht ist. Das kann sein.
Hast du da irgendwie eine Sichtweise, Andreas?
Ich habe da eine andere Sicht, weil ich Politikwissenschaftler bin. Aber ich finde es sehr wichtig, dass es eine innerparteiliche Oppositionsrolle momentan gibt, die sich aber auch darauf vorbereitet, Verantwortung zu nehmen, weil das immer...
Oppositionsrolle gegenüber was?
Momentan sind sie in der Opposition, sie haben keine Regierungsverantwortung.
Ach so, ja klar.
Aber das ist ja auch ein Lernprozess, der da stattfindet. Wie kann man sich denn auf so etwas vorbereiten, Verantwortung zu übernehmen? Ich finde, das ist ein sehr gutes Zeichen, dass diese Generation nun sagt, wir wollen Verantwortung übernehmen, wir wollen sie mit den uns eigenen Mitteln übernehmen, nämlich mit technischen Hilfsmitteln oder durch Technik vermittelt. Das Risiko hier ist sicherlich, dass es zu einem technokratischen Regime verkommt. Das ist ein Problem, das ich sehe. Das konkrete Beispiel von Liquid Feedback finde ich sehr praktisch, dass es dieses Experimentierfeld innerparteilich jetzt gibt. Ich weiß nicht, ob das gesellschaftlich irgendeine Zukunft hat oder nicht. Ich glaube immer noch bei Abgeordneten an das freie Mandat, so sehr es auch gerade nicht existiert aufgrund der Fraktionsdisziplin, aber eigentlich sollte das ja eine Gewissensentscheidung des Einzelnen sein können. Das heißt, eine verpflichtende Rückbindung ist schwierig, insbesondere weil man ja auch nicht weiß, wer beantwortet das denn. Gibt es dann irgendwelche Verzerrungen bei denjenigen, die zum Beispiel eine Abstimmung durchführen, sind das dann perspektivisch junge Menschen, die Zeit haben, die Zugang zu diesen Technologien haben und schließt es dann nicht die ältere Generation aus. Das heißt, wenn man sowas gesellschaftlich verpflichtend machen würde, gäbe es denke ich eine große Zahl von Problemen. Als innerparteiliches Experiment finde ich all das, was sie tun, sehr gut. Ich glaube auch, dass man diese Experimente nur dort fahren kann, weil die anderen Parteien zu unflexibel sind, weil sie zu etablierte Strukturen haben, weil sie einen täglichen Geschäftsbetrieb haben, der aufrechterhalten werden muss. Das ist bei der Piratenpartei egal. Die haben ja keine Verantwortung, keine Rolle. Das ist ja nur ein Experimentierfeld momentan. Die sind ja nicht in der Verpflichtung tatsächlich zu inhalten, Stellung zu nehmen. Das ist schön, wenn sie es tun, aber keiner zwingt sie. Und wenn es schief geht, dann geht es halt schief. Also ich sehe auch, selbst wenn die Partei verschwinden sollte, ist es ehrlich kein Problem darin, weil es ja genau dieses Experimentierfeld ist, um auszuprobieren, was kann Technologie hier helfen? Was kann es nicht lösen? Für soziale Probleme gibt es selten technische Lösungen, nur eher Unterstützungen. Computer sind ja auch nur Werkzeuge und Netze Strukturverstärker. Aber genau das mal auszuprobieren, was sind Effekte, die in diesem Transformationsprozess nun auftreten, und wie werden die verstärkt und wie können die abgefangen werden und welche Optionen bieten sich dadurch? Das finde ich sehr spannend. Insofern habe ich große Hoffnung in die Piratenpartei. Auch weil es von der Klientel her momentan ja ein überwiegend städtisches, bürgerliches, intellektuelles Publikum war anfangs im Vergleich zu zum Beispiel den großen Volksparteien. Da ist es halt eher so, dass es auch ältere Menschen sind. Dann gibt es immer die Trennung zwischen Arbeitern. Also diese ganzen soziostrukturellen Merkmale sind halt bei der Piratenpartei relativ eng, relativ überschaubar. Aber gute Startvoraussetzungen, denke ich, in Sicht auf die Ausstattung mit Fähigkeiten, Fertigkeiten und Technologien. Insofern betrachte ich das gespannt.
Also was ich bei euch heraus höre, ist sozusagen, ja, wie super, dass die Piratenpartei gibt. Die können jetzt irgendwie all die Experimente fahren, zu denen wir uns jetzt selbst noch nicht getraut haben im Club, sage ich jetzt mal so ganz spitz.
Aber wir sind auch keine Bewegung dieser Größe.
Wir sind vor allen Dingen keine Partei. Das ist eben auch mal ein ganz feiner Unterschied. Also wir sind eben keine politisch richtig einordnbare Strömung.
Wollte der Club ja auch nie sein, ganz bewusst.
Deswegen ist dieses Experiment bei uns auch nicht richtig untergebracht. Das ist bei der Piratenpartei schon richtig untergebracht.
Aber ich wollte jetzt noch was anderes hinaus, weil die Leute, die sich jetzt dort gefunden haben, das sind ja zu einem großen Teil Leute, die im Prinzip von den letzten 20 Jahren Digitalkultur auch schon weitgehend geprägt sind. Wir beide, Vic, haben das Anfang der 80er-Jahre mitgenommen. Du bist eigentlich vom Alter her auch genauso verortet ab den 90er-Jahren. Das ist ja ein Leben gewesen, was mit digitalen Medien, mit digitaler Gesprächskultur, wie auch man sie bewertet, groß geworden sind. Die haben irgendwie ein Stück weit Flamewar-Erlebnis schon mitgenommen. Was denkt ihr, was kann das für Menschen geformt haben? Habt ihr die Hoffnung oder die Vermutung, dass dort auch eine andere Gesprächskultur da ist? Oder ist das eine überhöhte Sicht? Ich glaube, dieses Selbstverständnis existiert in der Piratenpartei.
Ich frage mich nur, ob das stimmt. Ich bin ja nicht in der Piratenpartei und ich war auch noch nie bei...
Aber du kennst ja diesen Schlag.
Ich kenne die Leute, die in Überlappung mit dem Club sind. Das sind alles sehr vielige Leute und aufgeschlossene, interessierte Leute. Das ist schon mal der Hauptunterschied, den ich gegenüber den meisten Etablierten sehe. Und das ist auch eine gute Voraussetzung, um etwas Neues auszuprobieren.
Aber ob die repräsentativ für die Parteimitglieder, geschweige denn für die Wählerschaft sind, keine Ahnung. Vielleicht gibt es auch noch andere, die wählen. Ich kenne die ja nicht. Das Problem und die Chance, dass ich hier sehe, ist, dass diese Generation nach mir, also Menschen, die Ende der 90er, Anfang 2000, mit all diesen Technologien und dem sozialen Prozess ein bisschen aus sich rausgegangen sind, also die jetzt vielleicht 25-Jährigen, dass die ein Leben ohne diese Technologien nicht mehr kennen. Das ist, glaube ich, das Problem, was ich vorhin auch schon angesprochen habe mit diesem Technokratischen, dass das immer auch so ein bisschen als Selbstzweck betrachtet wird, die Maschine, und immer auch als omnipräsentes Element. Und das ist das Problem, das ich schlichtweg habe, ich möchte gerne mein Telefon ausschalten dürfen, auf den Berg laufen und in die Sonne schauen und einen Tag lang meine Ruhe von diesem ganzen Zirkus. Und das ist, denke ich, das Problem, das diese Partei herausfinden muss. Wie kann man all diese neuen Technologien einsetzen? Was ist die Technikfolge beim Einsatz dieser Technologien? Wie kann sie den Menschen unterstützen? Und welche negativen Auswirkungen wird das haben?
Das alte CCC-Mem, Chancen und Risiken. Genau. Nächstes Jahr wird ein 30 Jahre Club gefeiert, trotz undefinierten Datums.
Können wir einen Tag vorverlegen.
Was steht dann an? Wir können reinfeiern. Und was steht dann an?
Keine Ahnung. Bis jetzt weiß ich noch nicht, was dann ansteht.
Du hast ja deine Glaskugel vergessen.
Genau. Dann müssen wir uns noch mal zusammensetzen.
Ja, ehrlich gesagt, ich hasse auch so Diskussionen mit irgendwie die Zukunft von. Das lehne ich immer ab. Also bleiben wir jetzt hier mal bei ein bisschen Vergangenheit und Gegenwart und machen mal Schluss. Vielen Dank, Vic, Andreas. Gerne. Vielen Dank hier auch ins Publikum fürs Mithören. Ihr seid noch da, ja. Das war's. Das war Chaosradio Express 161 live von Ars Electronica. Also nicht live gestreamt, aber live gesprochen. Und wir sind noch am Leben. Ich sag Tschüss und bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.
Auf Wiedersehen!